this is Jocko podcast number 363 with
Echo Charles and me Jocko willink good
evening Echo good evening
all commanders should consider the
professional development of their
subordinates a principal responsibility
of command
commanders should foster a personal
personal teacher student relationship
with their subordinates
commanders are expected to conduct a
continuing professional education
program for their subordinates which
includes developing military judgment
and decision making and teaches General
professional subjects and specific
technical subjects pertinent to
occupational specialties
useful tools for General professional
development includes supervised reading
programs map exercises War Games Battle
Studies and terrain studies
commanders should see the development of
their subordinates as a direct
reflection of themselves
finally
every Marine has a basic responsibility
to study the profession of arms on his
own
a leader without either interest in or
knowledge of the history the theory of
warfare and the intellectual content of
his profession is a leader in appearance
only
self-study in the Art and Science of war
is at least equal in importance and
should receive equal time to maintaining
physical condition
this is particularly true among officers
after all and officer's principal weapon
is his mind
and that right there there's a little
excerpt from
defleet Marine Force manual one war
fighting
a book that was uh commissioned by
General Al gray the 29th commandant of
the Marine Corps and one of the most
iconic commandants of the Marine Corps
it's one of the first manuals that we
covered on this podcast
and what that excerpts describes is an
approach that I have
tried to take to study War to study
history
the theory of war the history of war the
profession of War
and have met
some folks along the way who are also
enthralled by the study of history and
warfare
and one of the most knowledgeable that
I've met is here with us tonight
his name is JD Judd J.D Baker he served
in the Marine Corps for 21 years
as an infantryman a sniper drill
instructor senior enlisted advisor in a
bunch of different billets deployed to
war zones around the world
and he's here with us tonight to share
his experiences and Lessons Learned with
us JD
thanks for coming by man thanks for
having me on uh let's get into it man
you've got so much knowledge that I want
to squeeze out of you and we'll get to
the end where we'll talk about how I
plan to squeeze knowledge out of you I
got a whole I got a whole campaign plan
on how to do that but let's let's talk
about you where you came from how you
grew up so when were you born uh 69
March 8th 1969. and and where uh
Huntington West Virginia uh right on the
Ohio River uh down on the South Eastern
side so you could basically swim to Ohio
and walk to Kentucky
that's a pretty good triathlon right
there yeah yeah the three-state
triathlon so what's your what's your mom
and dad do uh my mom was a stay-at-home
uh my dad uh he worked for a nickel
plant a big industrial kind of area down
there on the river uh you know West
Virginia coal nickel all that kind of
stuff and uh my dad hated his job
uh you know he had a suit and tie go
into work every day same uh kind of deal
and all he wanted to do was uh Scout
Major League Baseball uh so he put
applications out all over the place got
picked up by the Pittsburgh Pirates and
uh got to live out the rest of his life
uh scouting baseball did he did he quit
his job at the nickel plant uh he just
put in enough time to to get retirement
like as soon as like early retired so
it's kind of like in the military you
just do the 20 years what is he putting
on his application to become a major
league Scout I mean don't you have to
spend like time looking at high schools
then maybe you get a community college
that you go to a regular College then
you get to go to be a scout for the
Pittsburgh Pirates that's a big jump out
of the gate isn't it yeah it's a it's a
pretty big jump my dad played uh college
ball at Marshall so he played a little
bit of college ball and you know in our
household uh if it wasn't white with
little red you know stitches on it my
dad didn't give two about it so
basically we were raised in a Dugout
which was super cool for kids uh growing
up with me and my older brother so it
was it was strictly baseball he coached
uh baseball never like coached us while
we were playing little league my dad
coached Babe Ruth he coached some of the
travel teams stuff like that he was he
smart enough to realize that he
shouldn't coach you
uh he didn't like little kids okay
like he didn't want to be the one out
there like you know clapping for little
Johnny and Susie telling them they're
doing a great job uh you know I mean he
wanted like to elevate uh you know kids
that are you know 13 and above they kind
of know that they they know the basics
of the game was he doing like weird
subliminal stuff to you when you were
little to like was he like throwing the
Apple to you like oh hey hey Judd you
want an apple like tossed with you real
quick where you got to catch the work on
your hand eyes I feel like I did that
with my kids I was doing all this weird
kind of like things well the funny thing
is is like both myself and my brother uh
we we throw right but we bat left and I
don't remember ever
like it's kind of like learning to swim
like I don't remember when I learned to
swim and I don't remember learning how
to swing a bat but both my brother and I
both bat left-handed because in baseball
you have an advantage you're already
facing first when you get done swinging
so you've got to drop you can get the
first base faster so it was that kind of
thing right there I bet your dad was
like no no you need to stand over here
buddy stand over here or right so yeah
it was all out with baseball uh and of
course as a kid we love the game
um you know we played other sports as
well but baseball was what other sports
did you play uh we played soccer we
played basketball uh we you know play a
little bit of football but not as much
it was mainly it was baseball now you
played the other sports all the way
through high school or at some point did
we focus and just go like it's baseball
baseball and baseball well it was pretty
much like uh you know soccer was mainly
for the running aspect to be prepared
for baseball season like everything came
off of baseball uh you know basketball
my brother Russell because he wasn't
coordinated enough to play basketball
um so uh he wrestled uh you know I
played basketball love just a little
just a little thing here for for the
wrestlers out there I gotta say this
Jeremy Stevens you know he's a MMA
fighter and a great dude but he wrestled
in Iowa you know in high school and
stuff and and one of their insults they
would say if someone came into if they
wrestled against a guy or someone was in
the wrestling room they'd be like oh how
was that guy said oh he felt like a
basketball player meaning just like a
week
so when you say I'm just gonna throw
that out there for the wrestlers because
I can't let it go unchecked that you're
like too not coordinated enough to play
basketball so we wrestled and said so I
got to give some props to my wrestlers
out there yeah my brother on the
wrestling team you know of course he's
my older brother and of course is
wrestling friends would all come over to
the house and and want to you know put
the basketball player into a pretzel in
the middle of a family room on a daily
basis uh the only thing I liked about it
was when we sat at the dinner table you
know I didn't have to cut weight oh yeah
and my brother is over there just like
lettuce just shaking the water off and
I've got like a big thing of pasta and
just you know just woofing it down so I
always felt bad uh you know for my
brother in those aspects but uh you know
wrestling was was huge in West Virginia
you know at uh Huntington High where we
went to school uh coach Archer legendary
All-American wrestler coming out of
there uh we had some other Ken zephilado
guys you know Russell pan and games I
mean wrestling was huge so it was uh it
was a it was a real big deal but I I was
just thankful enough that that I didn't
have to like cut weight and you know and
the wrestling practices were just brutal
my brother would come back I mean
basketball practice and go shoot some
hoop Man play a little one-on-one you
know I mean it was like nothing
demanding uh you know what I mean you
were a little you know back then in the
70s those you know tube socks all the
way up little short shorts yeah little
short shorts put on a tank top man
that's what we're doing yeah you know
Watch Larry Bird Magic Johnson kind of
stuff but uh yeah you played basketball
so uh yeah I always yeah the wrestlers
that was that was Next Level uh you know
so did you so did you did you play three
Sports in high school then or did you at
some point just play baseball yeah it
ended up just being basically your Dad's
plan came together yeah uh and the other
position did you play I was a pitcher
how tall are you uh six foot three I
went and talked to the Padres a few
years ago and you know I don't really
follow baseball super close when I was
growing up it seemed like everyone that
played baseball was like a little
Dominican dude or a little Puerto Rican
dude you know like little guys and I
went and talked to the pondres every one
of those guys was a freaking giant human
Giant and I was like oh I guess it's a
huge Advantage I guess it's coming back
now where they got some smaller players
but it's a huge Advantage right to be a
pitcher and be six three oh yeah uh and
you know I started out as a kid I think
I was eight years old for my birthday
you know we didn't make a big deal out
of birthdays we just you know run into
mom and dad's room on your birthday and
they'd have a present for you and Mom
was a catcher's net because they thought
yeah my dad was like okay he's going to
be the short one so he'll be the catcher
you know I mean my older brother Tommy
he's gonna be the tall one so he'll be
the pitcher my dad was a pitcher he's
six foot three uh you know he's a big
guy I mean not like big unit kind of guy
that big uh you have six seven six nine
but
um then at like 10 years old my brother
quit growing and and I kept growing so
then we we reversed we just traded Mets
so then my brother became a catcher
which I was thankful for because again
as you can kind of see with like you
know a the basketball aspect a catcher
is a that's a brutal brutal job uh you
know I mean but you control the field
you're the leader uh you're the only one
that can see all eight players at one
time but you know being a catcher just
you know hot sweaty behind the plate
you're engaged in every play out there
and my brother was really good my
brother was a really good baseball
player uh as a catcher and then for me
being a pitcher you're kind of like the
yeah like a basketball player compared
to a wrestler you're the you know you
got to take care of the pitcher and you
know what I mean he's you know he's
special uh kind of aspect of it so I I
didn't get beat up as much as my brother
did and how about school are you doing
all right in school as far as like
grades and everything do you cares like
no big deal are you getting into trouble
what's going on with your just your
youth yeah uh School uh pretty much uh
get terrible just just terrible uh the
the coolest thing in school uh was in in
the first grade uh my my first grade
teacher was Mrs Gohan uh and miss going
cool thing about it is I'm friends with
her on Facebook even still today which
is like super cool with social media to
be friends with Miss gohing and uh and
she made us do a book report uh and
probably the biggest impact she had on
me was she let you pick whatever book
she didn't like assign a book to make us
read something specific you got to pick
whatever you wanted uh me I did my first
book report on Babe Ruth uh with the New
York Yankees obviously we had a lot of
baseball books in the house uh just
laying around uh everywhere
uh so she allowed me to write my first
book report uh and and then just to have
a love of reading it doesn't matter what
you read just read so uh after that I
always enjoyed reading as a kid but you
know I love gym class I like recess I I
like to play uh you know what I mean
whatever the game is it doesn't matter I
enjoyed playing a game and and uh and my
dad was always pretty you know he was
pretty liberal with the aspects of you
know boys will be boys kind of aspect
but my dad was a mathematician so he
loved math so and I'm the complete
opposite I I don't like math I'd rather
the liberal arts the history the reading
the books and stuff so uh yeah we kept
enough to play sports so you got to have
a 2.0 to play ball so as long as you're
above a 2.0 my dad was like well I'm
good with that you know what I mean it's
you know I wasn't an Honor Society or
holding candles having photos taken in
school uh but I had a lot of fun great
uh great childhood you got an A in
recess lunch gym class and fun yeah I
knocked it out the park uh in all those
areas uh and then you know where where I
grew up probably another big aspect of
my life was uh at eight years old my dad
sent me to camp
uh now this is a camp it's called Camp
Walla watula and it's in millboro
Springs Virginia Bath County on the cow
pasture River my dad went to this camp
and uh it's kind of like Hog's worth you
know like the Harry Potter stuff where
they would take us to the train station
in Huntington you'd have your your big
big luggage uh and you'd get on a train
and we would take the train to Clifton
Forge Virginia and the counselors would
pick us up from the train
throwed all of our luggage in there and
take us out to camp wallawatul on the
cow pasture River for seven weeks living
in tents
and it was like I loved camp
hunting you know you shot 22 rifles you
shot bow and arrow canoeing swimming
horsebacking you know orienteering Leaf
identifications not tying all these kind
of things and it was you know at Camp
wallowatula uh and I had to beg my
parents to go at eight years old because
normally you had to go when you were
nine but my older brother went and when
we went to go pick up my brother and I
got to see this Camp I was like oh this
is this is it like so we would spend
seven weeks every summer on the cow
pasture River at Camp which had a huge
effect uh on the rest of my life I mean
you know going into the Marine Corps was
like going to Camp you know what I mean
I mean you join the Infantry going to
Camp you know you got activity you did
that every year for like until you were
How old uh until I was 14 and then Don
Sutton the family that owned the camp
that like I said my dad went to that
camp uh that he had two sons and nobody
wanted to to take the camp over
so they basically shut the camp down but
every June uh we have a reunion uh with
all the guys at Camp guadalupula the the
sad thing is is like I'm one of the
youngest
uh of the re of the reunion guys and we
go back every June uh but being at camp
with uh the counselors and you know they
had a uh a big effect on me as a kid
growing up of like I mean you sat at
tables they taught you you know manners
how to eat you know how to take care of
yourself basically how to be a Virginian
um and every uh at the three and at the
three week Mark they would take us into
Lexington Virginia
uh you know vmis there and then they've
got the uh Robert E Lee tomb is there so
we would you know go visit Robert E Lee
so like at the first time at eight years
old yeah I remember seeing the Robert E
Lee you know Stonewall Jackson Virginia
uh all that Washington you know uh you
know Virginia and history is is huge uh
and and at Camp you know we had you know
mandatory like nap time you know after
lunch you'd come back and it was like
reading reading Lane Iraq kind of an
event so you know you could bring a book
you could write letters home uh the
letter writing really didn't go very
well I think my mom still has the first
letter I wrote and it was like dear Mom
and Dad having a good Judd and that was
it yeah you know what I mean and uh but
yeah it uh that that aspect of of
growing up and and seeing mentorship of
like the counselors that came into the
camp and they mentored us it you know at
a very early age and and seeing kind of
like what right looked like uh for
growing into becoming a man was uh was a
huge huge aspect that was an all-boy
campout it's all boys yep uh there was a
all girls Camp right down the river
called campmont Shenandoah still exists
today uh and you know we would do like a
dance with them and stuff we'd go up
River and and uh and and go there and
you know nice to see young girls in a
camp
so it was it was fun but um
yeah I mean the cow pasture river is a
is a part of my life I mean I've got
when I die I want to be cremated my
ashes dumped in the cow pasture uh we go
every year I mean I love the plate my
wife and I Tracy we were married in the
cow pasture River like standing in the
river uh yeah there's a that's a huge
tie to me uh it's that River in that
part of my life how far is that River
from where you grew up
probably about three and a half hours
three and a half hours four hours just
over the uh Appalachia it's on the uh on
the Virginia West Virginia border uh in
Bath County Virginia up in the uh
mountains up there beautiful part so
were you uh on track to like go to
college and play baseball were you good
enough were you like what was going on
with that well you know the good thing
is I had my older brother and so I could
kind of like watch what he did and see
his mistakes and try not to repeat you
know because you got to go home and deal
with my dad so my brother went to WVU uh
you know what I mean he was gonna going
to try the college thing and uh my
brother was a lot my brother was a lot
smarter than I was uh and but still he
couldn't figure out that you have to go
to class to like get a grade
did he get recruited for baseball was he
playing baseball there no no no he just
went yeah he was just you know going so
despite the efforts of your dad to turn
you guys into baseball players that
could play in college he didn't he
didn't play in college
no uh and if with my dad's aspect of he
more or less looked at it on the aspects
of try to go straight farm league like
you know I would say that my dad uh he
kind of looked at it like you can always
go to college you could be 60 years old
man you can go to college you get one
shot to play pro ball
and you know what I mean and you try to
get in you know if you can get minor
league uh kind of aspects uh he always
worried about like a college coach uh
you know what I mean of their pedigree I
mean they can they can ruin they can
ruin a guy uh because in College college
coach he's there to win he's going to
throw he's going to work you as much as
possible because that's his job
um and you know college baseball isn't
necessarily as like a big thing like
college football I mean for to play pro
football you got to go to college you
got to play college ball you're not
going to go direct to where like
baseball is more of a direct you know
the Derek jeters the the Griffies those
kind of guys you don't go to college you
go straight to the minor leagues and
then you work your way through the
minors so that was more of I would say
my dad's kind of uh take on things was
but your brother decided to go to
college yeah he was going to go to
college uh again my brother was real he
was good in school my brother was a lot
smarter than I was he paid attention a
lot more than I did so he went to WVU
but like I said he didn't go to class
much you know college football games
were great on Saturday kind of thing I'd
go up and hang out with my brother
and then he ended up uh you know not
making the grades and they're like yeah
you can't stay at school here anymore so
my brother he joined the Air Force
uh he's like yep well you know Dad's
like up knock knock don't want to hang
out in the house here let's let's come
back so my brother joined the Air Force
and uh and when he joined the Air Force
he was a uh worked on c-130s crew chief
stuff with c-130s he was out of Diaz
Texas uh I mean he seemed like a pretty
good gig for for what he was doing and
then for me you know when I was uh 17 I
played on a couple of travel teams
um and we were playing in Cincinnati uh
and you know regardless of uh of my dad
I mean I love my dad to death but uh you
know his nickname yeah between like me
and my brother and we called him the
dick
I love him to death but I mean you know
all my friends were like dude it must be
so cool having like you know because my
dad's nickname was T-Bone so they were
like dude it's like so cool like you
your dad T-Bone because everybody
thought my dad was great you know what I
mean like he was at all the games you
know whether it was football basketball
you name it I mean why did they call him
T-Bone just his name Tom Baker yeah he
was you know six put three you know 100
and you know 55 pounds it looked like
just the T-bone coming off of a steak
and uh so they called it T-Bone and
everybody thought it was like the
coolest thing was like well dude you
didn't live with my dad like of course
he's cool outside of the house but step
into the house and live with this guy uh
and again it was still it was it was
great uh
but uh you know my dad was I mean he was
he was funny humorous uh you know but uh
yeah I loved him to death but he uh we
we came back from playing in Cincinnati
Ohio uh and you know I I was throwing in
a game you know my dad and I kind of got
into it a little bit at the game uh and
I was like I'm done you know what I mean
I'm done I came back I went straight up
17. I went to the Marine Corps
Recruiting Office how did you how did
you hear about the Marine Corps uh I had
a buddy of mine uh actually I had quite
a few friends of mine of our class uh
there was a lot that went in the Marine
Corps uh Rick Shank uh was one of his
dad was a Korean Vietnam vet he was an
Army Ranger guy uh but you know uh there
was a lot of us that had looked at the
military uh in a in a in a blue collar
town like Huntington uh it's a way out
uh you know I mean so you get a lot of
folks that joined the the military to
get out you know what I mean like
there's something bigger out there and
it and again like I said I loved camp
and you know you know I don't have to
like those recruiters man they were
licking their chocolate I was an idiot
they're like oh you like camp we got
camp for you yeah I mean boot camp
you're gonna love it yeah and you know
and they've got activities they've got
tents yeah give you all this free stuff
you get a gun uh you know so yeah I mean
I was and I was like oh you know when I
when I came in there I was like you know
telling the recruiter I was like hey
I've got to be Infantry and you know and
he's you know giving us the look like oh
that's going to be a difficult one to
get you know what I mean like because we
didn't really know a lot and you know
and of course I I can get you you know
guaranteed yeah you know infantry you
know what I mean if you score high oh
yeah yeah I'm thinking like this guy's
the heat like he's looking us up until I
go to boot camp you know what I mean and
but then I'm 17 so I got to get a
signature so so you're 17 you're 17 are
you done with high school no no I still
have my senior year to go so I was like
delayed entry okay uh but I had to get
my mom to sign and what'd mama say mom
was all about she's get out for the
cause just yeah give me that paper let
me give you control here yeah yeah yeah
why even waste your time yeah which was
you know when you look back at like at
life of like a decision that you made at
a certain that was probably the smartest
decision I ever made because I would
have been a show for sure well I'm
right there with you thanks thanks my
recruiter I can't I don't remember
anything about my recruiter but I just
would like to thank him even though he
probably screwed me over he's like oh
yeah you're gonna go in the Seal team
sure buddy yeah you look you know oh
yeah you're gonna make a great seal
right that's such like there's
no way any recruiter knows if anyone has
the remotest chance to make it oh yeah
LCL teams you seem like the kind of guy
that's gonna do great there it's like
yep just sign this piece of paper sounds
great you know recruiter sir so those
guys are definitely hooking you up but
like that's the same with me that the
greatest thing probably like you said
the single pivot point of the trajectory
of my life was signing that piece of
paper and saying yep I'm in and I
remember I signed up for six years it
was six years to get up to get a seal
to get a buds contract where you go to
buds actually all it was actually all it
was was you sign up for six years and
that gives you a chance to take the
screening test to possibly pass to
possibly go to buds that's what it was
and and you know you're thinking you're
18 years old like six years along that's
one third of your life and I remember
just thinking well whatever rock and
roll let's do this
but definitely a pivot point huh that's
interesting because uh I they got me on
the sixth year but they gave you
infantry yeah I mean guaranteed
guaranteed guaranteed I wonder how many
bonus points he got for that that
recruited so you roll in there you
enlist now you're in you're going you
have to go to debt meetings your whole
senior year of high school or something
like that yeah yeah we kind of like meet
on the weekends and and you know and go
for runs and stuff like that so
basically you know my senior year was I
mean I think I took like four Gym
classes uh you know because I was like
okay I'm done like this is this is what
I'm gonna do so why do I need to and of
course you haven't played baseball your
senior year no I quit everything I mean
I I my dad was not happy I was going to
say yeah it was uh
but you know he he looked at it as I
don't think my dad was like a big fan uh
of of me making that decision uh of
going in the Marines
um but you know I mean when I remember
he took me down there to the recruiting
office to dropped me off because I
shipped like three days after graduation
like the recruiter was standing at the
graduation so when I walked across and I
got the piece of paper yeah they got
like take it to make copies yeah he's
there oh he's there but yeah I never got
this in the Xerox machine Son Well the
funny thing is there's like six other of
my classmates that are just as stupid as
me and we're all going to boot camp
together which is awesome kind of made
it fun yeah yeah so I had like Ricky
shank and Carrie Nestle or like
literally in the same recruit platoonism
yeah so it was kind of fun to wear when
you're seeing the drill instructor kind
of you know give them a ration and
you're over there trying not to laugh
but like what's going on and then
they're doing the same thing to you so
uh it was It was kind of nice like I
said it was kind of like going to Camp
you know I mean I had some of my friends
there that I'd known since you know I
grew up with them uh and and there was a
you know so it was it was cool to have
uh you know a couple of guys that I went
to school with and ran around with a lot
in my recruit platoon
but I didn't realize like and we were
all guaranteed infantry by the way yeah
I mean you know they don't make them
smart coming out in Huntington West
Virginia and uh and the recruiters
probably just you know he's loving it
um so until we like they're they're
announcing like your military MOS at the
end you know the senior drawstruck stand
up there he's like you know Baker
infantry you know I mean he's like
guaranteed boy you're some kind of
stupid you know what I mean but you know
back then like I didn't really know that
like there was other jobs like in the
Marines because I knew like you know
Navy dock you know we get a lot of our
stuff from the Navy you know I thought
like everybody went the Marine Corps to
be infantry and you know and then you
got cooked yeah every Marina Rifleman to
you was the facts yeah is it everybody I
was boot camp when you showed up was it
like a shocker or were you like holy
uh or were you just like hey Camp
let's do this yeah of course you know
the the shock and awe of you know when
they bring in I went to Paris Island uh
when I flew out of out of the Huntington
uh it's the Tri-State airport of what
they call it it and that was the first
time I had ever been to an airport
and I don't know you know the history of
Huntington of Marshall University you
might have seen the We Are Marshall uh
the 1970 plane crash that NCAA history
you know most fatalities
um and that was at that airport so where
I grew up the the whole Marshall
University and that plane crash November
14 1970.
uh you know every year in Huntington I
mean it is a it's a big deal uh for that
Marshall Marshall plane crash I had you
know kids that I went to school with
that you know their parents were on that
plane
um you know it devastated the community
in Huntington and then here I am going
to the airport
you know and and uh and I was like why
can't we just like take a bus it's South
Carolina man you know what I mean like
can we just so it was one of those props
that's got like the the little curtain
that the you know the pilot like puts
luggage on and then he takes the curtain
and whips it over there to the side and
you know what I mean
and where to and that almost stopped me
from going to boot camp I mean I was
like this is ridiculous man why are we
flying and uh so I got down there and
then they bring in at night
you know see you don't really know like
where you're going and it's you know
coming on to Paris Island of course you
hear all the Mystique of Paris Island
and of course you remember Full Metal
Jacket had just came out when you and I
were in high school so of course you
know that dude's like a stamina comic
yeah you know I mean that movie was
hilarious yeah you know what I mean and
and I'd probably say that with the the
drill instructors are they're they're
stand-up comics I mean some of the stuff
that they do is just it's Saturday Night
Live but it's like 18 hours of Saturday
Night Live a day and you're getting the
end the end of the joke yeah you're the
butt of all the jokes uh but it was
still it was a it was you know the shock
and all but then once we kind of got
into the rhythm of of boot camp then uh
you know with the drill instructors what
year is this is this 87 87 87. yep by
June uh so you know could have waited
till the winter time make it a little
bit more pleasant down there but yeah so
we uh ended up there in June graduated
in August you know three months uh down
there
um and then it went straight off to uh
Camp Lejeune uh went up to Camp Geiger's
where the Infantry school was at the
time and went through you know infantry
training school of 0311 you made it
oh 311 you made it how's that how was
that uh infantry School
uh
uh again you know um
kind of looking back on I mean it's it's
it's it's so many like new marines
coming in that you don't really like get
a lot of that individual uh education
how long was the school uh I think it
was like 10 weeks maybe did you have
Vietnam guys teaching you or not really
some of the older like the e7s and e8s
that were there were Vietnam era guys
but you know like the what you would
call like a you know the The Troop
handlers are more like the corporals and
the sergeants kind of so those guys are
you know coming in like the early 80s
and were there but the senior uh folks
yeah they were they were Vietnam Vietnam
era guys did you think you were going to
war at some point
yeah no uh yeah I mean it never really
even like crossed my mind uh you know at
the point um you know when uh like I
remember I listened to you we had like
uh when you and Dave when you had Dave
Burke on and you were talking about like
the Top Gun when like we grew up I was
more of the John Jay Rambo uh kind of
like being John Jay kind of turned me on
more than like Tom Cruise oh yeah for
sure you know I mean I couldn't relate
to Tom Cruise yeah I wanted like the
green ODI Green Jacket wear jeans boots
get a big knife with a like a compass on
the top of it you know what I mean with
matches in it and you know yeah I wanted
to be you know John Jay uh so you know
uh those aspects of it uh were pretty
interesting did you have like a global
perspective of the world and think well
you know it's the you know the the the
the the uh cold Wars going on you know
this could kick off did you did you have
any thoughts like that
yeah no yeah I was gonna say because I
you know I joined in 1990 now what
changed for me was that the Gulf War was
starting right so
when I came in it was like oh we're
going and I remember watching CNN and
CNN is saying there's going to be
something like 30 000 casualties in the
first 48 Hours on our side and I was
like oh bro we're going like I was
thinking it's on I'm gonna get some for
sure and then once that was over
it seemed like I just seem like well I'm
gonna be doing some kind of secret shits
going on you know like the SEAL Teams
come on we're doing stuff worldwide all
the time there's secret missions going
on I'm obviously going to Vietnam and
fighting whatever John J Rambo style for
that stuff but uh but going to the
Marine Corps 1987
the world was pretty pretty peaceful at
that time yeah you know in the Marines
uh we had uh one of the uh corporals
that was there uh that was at the
Infantry school he was a Beirut guy
uh so you know like back then like
Beirut was like which was huge for the
Marine Corps
um you know that that incident uh and
and so that was kind of you know Beirut
and Granada were pretty much like the
only two things and if you weren't with
like a specific one battalion then
everybody else in the Marine Corps you
know they just had the overseas
deployment ribbon with the Good Conduct
and and that's it you know what I mean
there wasn't any like solids hanging out
uh except for the you know the the
Beirut guys
um and then
I would say that uh my first uh
Battalion I got sent to was second
Battalion 8th Marines and it was on Camp
Geiger and all I did was was put my sea
bag on my back and face to the right and
we just walked down to the eighth
Marines barracks and it was open Squad
Bay
that's where that's where your first
assignment was they have a second beside
eighth marines that was on Camp Geiger
it was a eighth Marine regiment was on
Geiger everybody else was on Main side
Camp Lejeune and Geiger was open Squad
Bay
so it was and a lot of people talk about
like being an open Square I loved open
squat it was cam yeah I mean yeah it was
more camp but you know what I mean I got
up there you know you really get to know
like the guys in the platoon because of
the open Squad Bay I mean there's no
hiding from anybody it's not like at the
end of the day you go to your barracks
room and you shut the door and it's just
you and one other guy and the open Squad
bait people can walk through at any time
it's all your stuff's exposed you get a
Foot Locker and a wall locker and that's
it so you didn't really you know like
nowadays like kids move into their rooms
and they got TVs they got Xbox they got
all this kind of stuff you couldn't have
that stuff
you know because you had one TV in the
Duty NCO controlled what channel it was
on uh but yeah so it was it was uh it
was pretty cool uh on those aspects and
then you know as soon as I got second
Battalion eighth Marines my first
um my first training op was uh cold
weather training up in Bridgeport
California oh that's cool which was
banging yeah uh you know I mean they got
ski lifts up there we're skiing of
course that was the first time like you
uphill like with a pack which that's
exactly yeah not as cool you know what I
mean like I wanted to go to like Tahoe
and do some downhill and then of course
you know Marine Corps with our
mountaineering skis are low is bitter so
it's like two by four strap with uh you
know what I mean with a boot band
wrapped around your Mickey Mouse boots
and you're gonna head down the hill with
a 90-pound rook on and a rifle hanging
off the front of you uh that was the
only point that uh that I was really
excited that I wasn't a machine gunner
you know what I mean like skiing with a
with a machine gun there's a whole
nother level
and how long were you at 2 8 for I was
at uh two eight for I stayed from just
at the end of 87 right into 89. oh so
you did years there this is your first
assignment yeah yeah this is my first
Battalion what do you do did you go on
deployment from there yep uh so we did
like the Bridgeport thing you know you
do like your workups but did you do you
you did a workup but did you go like get
on a boat and go on deployment to the
met or something like that well we
actually did Westpac because uh we came
in flew over to Okie and then my first
boat ride was on the USS Fort McHenry
right on uh which you know as a as a kid
in Camp like I read like yeah I I enjoy
reading uh and and books on adventure uh
you know I mean and I always thought
like like when I look at like a Navy
ship it's kind of like being in
Huntington West Virginia it's a
blue-collar community a float so these
are like all the guy like in the Navy
like they they got guys that like have
jobs like they do stuff diesel mechanics
yeah yeah you know what I mean and like
we're in the Pacific you know what I
mean and it's just like it you get to
see how small you actually are but you
know being with the the Navy Marines
don't have a job on the boat yeah I mean
we get up we our point of place of Duty
is in the round back we stand in chow
line a lot you know what it made us like
get done with breakfast what are you
gonna do I'm gonna wait for lunch don't
wait for lunch stand in line and sit
there with a book and when the Navy gets
pissed off that the Marines are laying
around all over their stuff they call
General quarters and we go to the rack
and and you know and they go to work but
uh yeah I was always intrigued with the
Navy like you know and then just the
global of travel uh and a like a Navy
ship captain uh always it seemed like a
super cool job to have being a you know
aboard a ship and it's so blue-collar I
mean the guys in the Navy aboard the
ships you know we floated Gator Navy uh
but they were like super great guys they
all had skill sets from you know
electricians to the laundry the cooks
the I mean it just uh it was it was like
you know being in Pittsburgh yeah yeah
except everybody doesn't have a mullet
you know what I mean they got a haircut
uh and it's like you're afloat with a
blue-collar town and it was a it was
super cool we went to Korea uh you know
what I mean so and that was one of the
things that intrigued me about just
joining the Marines was I was going to
get the travel
and get paid like you know I mean I get
to go to cool places and you know so you
know going to Korea going to Japan
Philippines you know those kind of
aspects and I'm getting a paycheck at
this are you guys doing exercises there
yeah like team spirit yeah you know all
those little names that they have for
stuff because you know we're fighting
Ivan so everything's in Ivan yeah uh and
you know we just we go out we we go to
the field we run exercises we come back
and then we get like you know like four
or five days off uh and in 88 uh the
Olympics were in Seoul Korea so that was
so you were there for that yeah like
would you guys work security or anything
or no no yeah would the Marines stay
down in pohang right outside of pohang
and it was called camp moonchuck we
called it Mud Chuck uh you were still
burning there yeah I mean it
was primitive
primitive camp this is where you guys
when the when the ship pulled in that's
where you went yep the Navy would kick
us off uh you know what I mean and then
we'd go into to Camp Mud Chuck and and
we'd go into there but you know and then
they had ranges we would you know do
company exercises but tie and exercises
you're a straight Rifleman in a platoon
straight Rifleman just that's it uh
Rifleman
I loved it I mean I mean like being a
rival you just you get a rifle yeah uh
it was it was super yeah it was super
cool the guys in the platoon you know
you got all these different characters
just from all over that just make things
like so interesting just you know of
hearing the stories and their background
where they grew up uh you know and and
you know back then we didn't really
intermix a lot with like the platoon
Commander you know what I mean like our
biggest uh is usually like your squad
leader because he controls your life and
then the platoon sergeant is a big role
and you know like the lieutenant you'd
like see him at like formation or
something you know what I mean because
like you didn't stay in the same you
know officers are segregated out to you
know and then you just what we you know
they're not in cell block uh you know
what I mean of like where we're hanging
out back when the Marines had didn't
even have name tags on their uniforms it
was just like what's your name my name
is corporal yeah that's it you can call
me Marine if you want yeah I wrote a
point on ships because I I did a few
deployments where I did three
deployments on ships with Marines and
one with the carrier strike group but
yeah the Marines were just another I
have to tell the story we you know it
was a pain to get off the ship when you
pulled in when you hit the pier because
as soon as they rang the Liberty Bell
everyone was in line to get out and it
would take like an hour or more to get
to get through that line so we used to
ship pulls in gets pure side as soon as
they call for Liberty we'd go to the gym
and get a good workout because the
ship's not moving and there's no one in
there because everyone's trying to go on
Liberty so this one time we do that you
know get done go go work out get done
take a shower put on our Liberty clothes
it's been like an hour and a half and we
go up to the quarter deck to leave
and they're carrying a freaking Marie
back who's so wasted he got wasted in an
hour and a half he was unconscious drunk
bro that's how hard he was going in the
paint so that's you know good times for
Marine Corps that's usually uh every
every board call I mean somebody's gonna
ruin it uh and and you know the thing
that I always tell them ring I mean it's
almost like uh being in jail like if you
go to the first Port call and you you're
done training in the first hour and a
half and then you get restricted to the
boat for six months of restriction I
mean that's prison yeah that's the
sentence yeah you know everybody else is
like you know hitting it and you know
but it's you know when you when you when
you keep everybody you know caged up
down there in cell block and you're
crossing the pond and then you know you
hit this Liberty port and you're like I
mean you're you're 18 19 years old
and you're you're legal drinking age
everywhere in the world but here you
know what I mean and of course you know
but you've been in like training so you
know through boot camp and infantry
school so it's not like and you can't
have beer in the barracks because I
lived in an open Squad base so it wasn't
like we even have refrigerators yeah so
any chance you guys you spent like two
and a half three years living in an open
Bay Barracks yeah oh yeah it was uh I
loved it I mean we used to like take the
wall lockers those old gray water and
put them up against the walls and you
know and we would play hardball baseball
like because you couldn't break anything
I mean it was like you know just the
Antics that went on and you know the
only bad you know like back then you
could still smoke in the government
areas and even on ship I mean I can
remember being on the boats and just
like you'd go into the to the cell block
area where the Marines are down there
and they're just like that Haze of smoke
across the top but you know guys just
laying around with it like Oak can
flicking ashes in it you know it was uh
it was a different different world did
you did you know you're like you found
your place when you got in the Marine
Corps were you like oh this is I'm I'm
good I've got my job forever
yeah uh yeah I mean it was like I'm
gonna just go to camp for the rest of my
life uh you know and the funny thing was
is you know uh you know we you talked
about Al gray so this is 87. uh he
became the commandant while I was in
boot camp uh so I mean you talk about
just a different
kind of guy
of of Al gray I mean is what a lot of us
consider the second Enlightenment of the
Marine Corps uh and and this guy is all
about education it's all about he wants
a university uh you know I mean I give
you probably the the coolest story of Al
gray I met him in 89 uh first Battalion
six Marines were looking for folks to do
contingency operations in Panama Noriega
was running the joint down there so I
left 2A joined one six uh to be able to
go do uh contingency operations in
Panama you know I mean I thought one
Panama Triple Canopy jungle it's got to
be cool uh you know I mean and it was
just another experience to be able to so
um I I went to one six and and I was
down there
um and we stayed at the Rodman Naval
airport uh Naval Base down there right
on the canal they had the Howard Air
Force Base it's down there and then the
Marines operated out of what was called
all the arahan tank farm it kind of
looked like If you flew over top of it
it looked like a golf course cut in the
middle of the Jungle it was all like the
the tanks for refueling coming through
the canal and just seeing the Panama
Canal was like the greatest engineering
like I had ever seen like before because
it used to be the Panama path you know
they used to just walk across because it
was the skinniest point and to watch the
locks and the ships come through the
canal was just amazing see you know for
a 19 year old kid like seeing the Panama
Canal and you know of reading about it
it was just it was an amazing experience
but we would go out and you were on like
a six day rotation and you know you did
two days in in the fob uh which was just
out in the middle of the Jungle it was
the Ford operating base and then you
would do two days on patrol and then
they'd bring you back for two days in
the rear and you were just on this
rotation and there was a just a company
of Marines down there I was in Navy Navy
Seals were down there you know they had
Army folks down there
um but that was our assignment and I
remember
um Al gray it was the commandant and I
was in the fob and I'm I'm sitting in
the fighting position we had fighting
positions around there so I was you know
man in the fighting positions me and one
other guy and the heat Taps going down
it's getting dark and we kind of can see
like this Entourage of people Milling
about the area and it just not it's not
making too much sense of like like who
is this well the next thing you know
this older guy I mean it's dark out I
really don't know who it is he hops down
in the in the in the fighting position
with me and he's like hey who are you I
was like thanks Corporal JD Baker you
know what I mean and he's like okay
how's things going I was like who who
are you I was like Al Gray
and name sounds familiar
you know I mean because like you know Al
gray was just you know our great Marine
I mean that's just how he went by uh and
he was a prior enlisted uh you know
infantry uh made it all the way to
Sergeant and they thought he'd make a
good officer so they sent him to OCS uh
and made his way up through the ranks
from New Jersey uh he was a baseball
player so he started asking me just I
mean of anything going on just asked me
like who are my parents
like what you what's my dad do what's my
mom do kind of like the stuff how you
and I when we first got on just started
asking me those personal questions and
when I told him about my dad with
baseball he was like you know he like
lit up like because he was like you know
I played Semi-Pro baseball up in New
Jersey they call he was called the
Pelican pounder he was a hell of an
African pounder yeah he played for the
Pelicans it was a semi-pro team up there
and he literally like years later I was
up at his house in Alexandria and he's
showing me the the front page picture he
had the clipping you know I mean Pelican
pounder Al gray which was pretty cool to
see so he was a big baseball guy
and uh and for me being at E3 I was the
last Corporal at that time with the
comment on the Marine Corps I have now
had a relationship with that guy for
35 years
which was just amazing he was just a
different how did you stay in touch with
him after that
he just reconnect with him later he's
always been around the Marine Corps like
you know Al gray is for sure yeah I mean
he's just one of those guys like we
could be sitting in here doing this
podcast the next thing you know he'd
just show up I mean because that's how
he was is like a Commodore he didn't
tell people when he was going places I
mean he just uh his career he was the
first one to just take his official
photo and cami's uh you know the the
kind of guy that he was uh that really
uh had a had a big effect on on me was
when he was the commandant of the Marine
Corps on the weekend he was out front of
his commandant's house at 8th and I you
know down in Southeast DC and he's out
doing the gardening at the front of the
house and this elderly black woman that
lived down the street was walking by and
and she was you know stopped and said
hello and you know Al gray was like hey
how you doing didn't say like who he was
she just thought he was the gardener and
she's like man I've lived here in
southeast you see my entire life and
I've always wondered what it looks like
on the inside of that house
so Al gray was kind of like interesting
so goes to a staff meeting on Monday and
he's like I'm having a garden party and
I'm inviting all my neighbors
so they send out invitations to block
radiuses all around you know eighth and
I and he's inviting of course you know
he's got staff guys going okay we're
going to put a rope here let's take this
thing down I mean because they got a lot
of like a chesty puller's underwear in
there or something I don't want somebody
to take you know what I mean now Grace
like no man it's these are my neighbors
like do you like when your neighbors
come over do you put stuff away do you
put ropes up and they're only allowed in
certain sections of your house these are
my neighbors and sure enough man he has
his party and the neighbors are all
coming in and here's that elderly black
woman comes in and who she meet at the
door Al gray she thought he was the
gardener and there he is I mean when
they got done with the end of the event
not one thing was stolen nothing broken
you know I mean and the Marines up at
8th and I weren't having any more
problems out in town anymore with the
neighbors in and around southeast DC it
was just an extended hand of these are
our neighbors and that's kind of sums up
of like who Al gray is so he had a huge
effect on the Marine Corps just in that
four-year period of time and and I just
got lucky enough to
to meet him uh in Panama in 89 and just
stayed in contact in his memories just
like he could remember like
exact dates names of the guy's got a
phenomenal memory and he was
self-educated
you know I mean he was number one thing
was was the library you know what I mean
get a book read it and you know now
Marine Corps has the reading list which
is kind of cool we got a lot of cool
books on there you know what I mean so
you go through the different grade
levels and you know you can get books
and and the Marine Corps was always
really big into their history and big
into the reading which one that fell in
line with me love history uh love the
love the reading aspect of it and you
know reading if this is going to be your
trade if this is what you're going to do
then you need to read a lot of books and
you know I had some uh other officers
you know one uh Eric Carlson he told me
to cast my net widely
like don't just pigeonhole like just
don't read all military you know what I
mean so cast your net widely so you get
a you know a different perspective on
different things and and uh so that was
uh that was had a that was pretty cool
uh with with Eric
um you know and cast them on that so I
mean I read from Danielle Steel uh
anything that I could get my hands on
just to be able to to read uh and the
imagination Rudyard Kipling uh you know
Henry David Thoreau I even read some uh
theoretical physicists the Cork and the
Jaguar which was like that'd be a cool
job to be like a theoretical foot just
like sit in a room like this and I just
think for eight hours and of stuff and
you know go back but that was uh that
was that was pretty cool were you where
were you when the invasion went down in
Panama
uh we were uh The Invasion we were back
uh Stateside because we were rotated in
you went down on a 90-day tour uh you
did a 90-day uh and then rotated back uh
so that was in in 89 uh but that was
also I was a that was a fire team leader
uh so that was like my first uh go
around being a fire team leader and and
that was probably my first realization
even though like nothing nothing
happened like we didn't get any gun
fights while we were down there there
was events that were taking place just
me personally I I didn't have any events
uh but when you get issued live you know
issued live ammo and you take the BFA
off the you know what I mean it got real
like then I was kind of like okay this
this is this isn't like Camp anymore
like you know what I mean but being in
Triple Canopy down there and you know we
went they used to have Fort Sherman the
army base it was down there and you go
through jungle uh jungle warfare and
jungle survival a phenomenal place you
know when they take you down there they
got like this little zoo that like like
show you the animals that you can
encounter while you're there dude it
wasn't the Panamanian Defense Force that
we were scared of it was the the
creatures in that jungle uh when like
seeing like the Anaconda you know what I
mean it was like that that's a big
that's a big snake I was I was lucky
when I was at Seal Team one we were like
the designated Southeast Asia
team and so we were supposed to be ready
for the jungle in our platoon work up
getting ready to deploy we went and did
like a month in Panama we went to that
Zoo all that stuff went to that Army uh
jungle survival training
I don't know if we went through like a
full school it was like a couple like a
day and a half or something like this
they're you know showing you what to
watch out for and all that kind of stuff
but it was awesome you know then we went
we just went out and lived in the jungle
for like a month and we had a little
base camp set up and we'd go out and do
our training throughout the day we would
do we would do occasionally we'd try and
do night immediate action drills which
is like completely black there's a no
night vision days you know just
completely black running through the
jungle sending up a loom you know
hitting trees with your loom by accident
because I was a radio mix I was always I
was always firing a loom it was freaking
awesome
you get you get good when you when you
spend that much time in the field you
get good at it yeah and doing the three
months down there that's where I would
say that I got good at being an
infantryman uh but it was uh yeah that's
a that's amazing you're talking about
like you know the because when it got
dark oh I mean remember that he is black
well dude do you remember those mvgs we
had back then to wear like the Starlight
stuff to where okay well one it requires
star life yeah we didn't even use those
down there and then you'd be in the
radio operators I don't know what you
got remember we had the 77s uh the prick
77s the 104s you know what I mean to
where like you had to be good oh yeah
yeah with skills yeah yeah I mean it's a
skill set yeah to run com like when I
look at the communications that these
folks have nowadays it's like wow like
trying to get a calm shot with a 77 or a
104. uh was yeah that's when the
communicators had some serious skill
sets uh to be able to to manipulate
relate and operate calm especially down
there that was the first time as like
being a team leader I had to do like you
know
Patrol overlays so I had to I had to get
good at my job
um and and I would say that that
probably was the The Pinnacle of like
those three months but down there I I
that's when I became an infantryman you
know as what we would call it because an
o311 is you're a scout
is basically uh is pretty much what you
are
um and then that had a big effect on me
uh as being a marine of what's important
as far as like training and education
wise of becoming a professional
infantryman uh was really big so it's
not too long after that that the Gulf
War starts heating up the first Gulf War
yes and so where how do you how do you
slot into that you're at one six now
yeah I'm uh same Battalion I was in
Panama with uh we got a new platoon
sword when we came back uh that guy his
name was Eli Tucker uh his nickname was
Eli Tucker the big because
that dude was jacked uh you know what I
mean and just ruthless but a hell of an
empty he had a huge impact on me he was
a sergeant E5 uh but that guy when when
I when you like if you look up Marine
infantryman in the dictionary it's Eli
Tucker is in that book uh he's just a
phenomenal guy uh both up and down the
ladder he he pulled respect from the
officers as well as as any enlisted in
that Battalion uh and and so he was my
platoon sorry we were on on deployment
uh again over in the Far East and uh we
hopped in we were in the Philippines and
Noriega decided to add on to his you
know Southern Property so Oh you mean uh
Saddam Saddam I mean uh yeah so he takes
over uh he goes over uh snatches up
Kuwait we're in the Philippines they
throw us on the USS broken Iowa the
Okinawa uh and we steam around and they
kick us off the boat and we're in
country uh right there coming in
September so it went down in August they
had us in we were one of the first
Marine battalions uh to hit the ground
uh in Saudi Arabia and then it was just
so did you stay there the whole time yes
how long were how long were you there
for like seven and a half months yeah it
was terrible
uh it was uh it was living in a tent in
the desert basically we didn't even have
the test yeah we had those radar
scattering Nets kind of things so you
just you know and Poncho
yeah we were just for for how long did
you live like that we were out there for
like over seven months
yeah it was terrible you had to have a
cot you know those little green cots
because the the desert sand was just so
hot uh but the cool thing was about the
Battalion you know we kind of talked
about earlier my Battalion Commander was
uh
Lieutenant Colonel Jones
uh and his his initials were TC so we
called him too cool uh and Jones was a
phenomenal uh Battalion Commander uh
Jones uh with with he was the kind of
guy that uh he like knew everybody in
the Battalion he knew where you were
from he knew a little bit about he was
very personable uh so you know and that
was almost like every Marine battalion's
their leadership were all Vietnam vets
uh so they knew what was important of
what we needed to know uh there wasn't
uh you know um and then you go up to the
regimental level and then you've got Al
gray as the commandant you know you got
uh storm and Norman Schwarzkopf you know
what I mean Army commander and then
joint Chief she got Colin Powell kind of
so it's almost like the stars have
aligned
you know when someone folks are like
yeah Desert Storm was like what like 96
hours there's a reason for that mm-hmm
because of those guys we're like yeah
we're not doing this one again
and I mean when when we were it was a
long wait uh that was a and what are you
doing while you're waiting just training
every day prepping getting ready yep
trying on your gas mask trying on your
gas mask again trying on your gas mask
again did you get were you guys hearing
this casualty thing that I saw on CNN
like hey there's going to be Mass
casualties were you expecting that were
they briefing you on that yeah they
actually uh flew in a whole bunch of
Replacements uh you know right prior to
the ground war kicking off and we're
like what are these dudes doing here you
know what I mean and they're like oh
these are the replacement guys you know
what I mean of coming in so you know I
would probably say like I got I got
really sick of the gas mask uh but when
they show you like photos and stuff of
like what people look like with blister
agent and
like that was like a that was a real
threat like everybody was like scared
for those aspects of the chemical minds
and our Battalion we we had the mine
belts uh of blowing the mine belts that
were out there uh which was you know
interesting within itself uh you know
when so that was your mission yeah was
it well we had to get through those mine
belts first so there was two big mine
belts so we got the we're all
everybody's mucked up
uh and you you got the uh the the lines
that can shoot over the back of the uh
the amtraks and detonate and give you a
kind of a lane kind of a thing to go
through uh some of them work some of
them didn't so we had that yeah we had
tanks uh that were there with us uh the
tanks that were attached to us I
remember their call sign because it was
Public Enemy uh which was like a super
like you're gonna be like a tank guy
that's like a that's a cool it's a great
question I like Public Enemy uh and you
know those guys would come through and
push the plows uh and just the the the
air power the amount of support and
being in o311 like on the ground
I I felt like I didn't even need a gun
I mean the kitchen sink was being thrown
at these folks I mean they were just it
was it was all on it was like a live
fire exercise so when it kicked off what
was your what was your what was your
platoons mission uh breaching getting
through and then they had like on the
other side of the mine belts was
Defensive positions for the Iraqis so we
all had certain objectives that we kind
of had to hit and uh you know just to
get through the my belts they thought it
would take like days for us to get
through the mine belts not a couple of
hours and then we had the Army's tiger
Brigade that was following up they were
the ones that were going to do the big
uh left uh the big left hook going up
into Iraq with I mean I'd never seen so
many Bradley's a M1 Abrams because
remember that's when the M1 came out the
Abram which that thing is that's a
badass piece of gear sure and uh just so
we did the mine belts they broke left
they start heading up to Iraq and we're
when we hit their the objectives for our
company objectives and so these are like
little Iraqi positions these were your
company objectives it was like little
pill boxes or whatever yeah if even that
I mean they had been sitting out there
for so like we had these extravagant
like what we thought we were going to
encounter and then what we actually
encountered were not the same like some
couple sandbags and a dude with an AK
yeah I mean and they were like in living
quarters like they had been out there so
long just like us like you're just
trying to make your life comfortable so
get some plywood you know what I mean
dig a hole put it over top of it you
know what I mean make a nice little area
you know you can Brew up Ramen you got
your coffee that kind of stuff they're
just basically out there living in the
the front line troops like weren't the
Republican guard guys they had those
guys behind them to make sure that they
didn't run run away
um and so you know as soon as you start
coming through is basically we we hit
them and just everybody Flags oh yeah I
mean because they were like oh my God
they're they're here already
you know like their their coffee pot was
like still warm you know what I mean
when we rolled in and uh then it was
just it was just a Rolex I mean once we
went through the of course you know
everybody you know you're scared I mean
you know when you on the other side of
the mine belts and they're they're
dropping artillery and those sorts of
things they're coming on so you can you
can hear the explosions you know the you
know they set the oil fields on fire so
you've just got like that oil fields and
the black smoke and all that kind of so
it's like where you freaking stoked
but yeah to be there and just like hell
yeah yeah and then let's get the hell
out of here so how long did it take
before you got your objective secured
and then what you do oh and we load it
up straight to Kuwait I mean and it was
it was just game on I mean we we uh we
rolled it that air war and that campaign
that those folks did
unbelievable I mean it wasn't like a
window pane left
intact in Kuwait I mean they they they
like I said they threw the kitchen sink
at them I mean the the air power above
us even with our with our helicopter
support with Cobras army with their
Apaches and then all the fast movers and
stuff over there I mean they just there
was a lot of craters that mile of death
because I remember years later probably
like I think it was 90
93 or 94. I went to Kuwait and we were
doing like training and we drove up the
mile death and there's still Vehicles
all over the place that we just blasted
oh yeah and then you know then they they
want to make it look like the kuwaitis
like
had a part in it so then they're gonna
let them come back in and you know shoot
into the air and yeah we took our
country back and all that kind of stuff
but yeah that place was a wreck it's
amazing what it looks like now uh
compared to yeah I mean they they uh
they they took the wood to it but it was
you know of seeing that in in 91 and
just seeing the the amount of power
the United States has is just
unimaginable of of what we can bring to
bear
but I look at the commanders that were
those senior commands you know a few
years later after that I read Colin
Powell's autobiography phenomenal uh
individual phenomenal career but I look
at those guys in the in the leadership
positions of of where they were and
their careers of what they had gone
through coming out of Vietnam and seeing
that kind of stuff so when you know now
it's their turn to go
I was very thankful for that but even
the Battalion commanders you know them
having combat experience
you know what I mean it was a it was it
was a game changer for us to have
somebody uh that you know directly
looking out for you that that's been
there done that has the t-shirt and hat
kind of aspect and and they know what
right looks like uh and the way they
were as Leaders like I said I mean two
cool Jones was uh as the Battalion
Commander he was
you know just phenomenal as a leader
because he was personal
like you felt like you had a
relationship with the guy
and and of course you know he always had
he loved Sports you know it was big and
with activity so you know we had
softball bats I played third base for
his you know for his Battalion team you
know what I mean so third base and you
know I got an arm uh yeah you know what
I mean love playing you know so it was
like camp but you know what I mean again
but we're in the middle of the desert uh
yeah it's it's it's uh you know you
mentioned that you had these guys
who were running the show and you know
when when we just had this Afghanistan
pull out which is just a big disaster
you look at the entire the entire
Afghanistan campaign in the Iraq
campaign that that that took place when
I was in
did these people learn anything from
Vietnam
and then you look at how those guys
handled the first Gulf War it's like you
know they learned something from Vietnam
like we're not gonna do it like that
we're gonna go in there with
overwhelming Force
I mean overwhelming times five like
there's nothing's gonna stop us and
we're gonna end up doing this in three
days that's what's gonna happen and like
you said
people go it's only 96 hours it's like
yes exactly
yeah I'm thankful for that uh you know
and and that that was a a huge uh
turning point of course uh by then
um
you know then I I had known when I came
back that you know the Marine Corps this
is this is what I'm gonna this is what
I'm gonna do I've got you know three
deployments
uh and then you know then they're
looking at now you gotta kind of
diversify yourself a little bit uh so
when I came back
did you guys come back on a ship how did
you guys get back how did you guys get
back to America because we were the
first then we got to be the first out
and there was a call of all Airlines
worldwide to come in to pick up troops
to get them home we flew uh Hawaiian
Airlines uh which was uh which was
pretty banging uh you know what I mean
being out being gone for over nine
months you know total because we were
already on deployment and then uh got
tag you're it uh and you know getting on
the on the big freedom birds and we
landed in uh we we flew over we landed
in uh in Ireland uh to refuel and then
we landed in Maine uh and we landed in
Maine they let us get off the planes and
we all came back in and we were like the
first like troops back to hit U.S soil
in Maine and man the the airport was the
walls were lined with just it seemed
like the whole state of Maine was at the
airport you know what I mean Flags they
had tables out food and you know uh the
Battalion Commander you know I mean he's
like meet me at the bar and you know we
go to the bar here's probably not the
smartest thing to do with you know
you've been sober for nine months and
now we're all gonna go to the bar
and uh but I mean the people in Maine
for them coming out which is huge uh the
support that we got uh coming back after
that was amazing uh so we're there they
refuel they put us back on the on the
bird and you know the the stewardess
just had to lock themselves away because
you got a bunch of stupid brains that
have had a lot you know they got the
little no smoking lamps coming on dudes
are burning cigarettes you know there's
no shits given we get down to Cherry
Point and the bands down there I mean
they're throwing 12 packs and beer on
the back of the uh five tons we're going
back down to Lejeune it was I mean it
was a great great uh homecoming uh to be
able to to come back and it was uh it
was it was phenomenal uh uh for that
experience
um and then I had to decide of what I'm
what I'm going to do next and uh I had a
one of my uh best friends Doug Berry he
lives just up the road here in San Diego
uh we were uh together in first
Battalion six Marines
and uh we both went over uh to await
orders to go to the drill field
uh to become a drill instructor
um and just because you know I'm in the
Marine Corps like the the DI is a very
iconic for sure uh figure but the bigger
reason is is back then you only had to
do two years on the drill field
but if you went recruiting you had to do
three well the only thing I knew was I
did not want to be a recruiter like that
you know I would God bless them uh you
know I mean we've got the school right
here at MCRD for Marine Corps Recruiting
and the guys are great at their job uh
you know the Marines put on the you know
the uniform the way they look the way
they recruit I mean we can propaganda
with the best of them out there
and uh so I I wanted to go do the DI
thing get the funny hat uh plus it you
know it would be fun uh and and it was
uh it was how long so how long is drill
instructor school it's like three months
it's kind of like you're going through
boot camp but you got rank
mm-hmm
it I imagine though they must be like
even harder in boot than boot camp in
some ways because you got to be so like
perfect with everything
yeah and it's learning like the the
drill manual verbatim uh it's the from
the mannerisms to just the the command
presence they teach you that oh teach
can they take a guy that doesn't have
any command presence and they teach it
to him oh yeah I mean you're gonna stand
out there and yell at a lot of trees you
know what I mean just like if you ever
go down there and you like watch Di
school and they're going through the
high school you'll see dudes like what
is he doing yelling and they just went
at a tree well he's doing what likes
called a teach back where you have to
verbatim you know what I mean like go
back through for the the different uh
moves of of drill and then you know from
your mannerisms how you dress how you
look your professionalism uh of of
coming in is it it is it's a it's a
difficult School the uniforms uh are
just I mean that's next level uh you
know because I wasn't like the best
uniform guy you know I mean yeah yeah I
wasn't
like I didn't even own dress blues like
I because you had to buy him back then
if you wanted them and I was like why do
I want to buy them you know what I mean
I like the alphas the the grains uh so I
I just had Alphas I Never Had the Blues
they didn't issue them to me and you
know I mean I'm cool with that I didn't
join to get dress blues
um I joined for the Camis and the rifle
free ammo that kind of stuff travel the
world uh so when I got there the
uniforms were difficult the PT uh was
really good but it was it was more of
the structure of everything that they do
to you at the high school you can use it
when you become a drone instructor so
they're gonna do stuff to you that then
you can turn around and Mark what
uh like on the training schedule of like
of you know probably the the biggest
misconception uh of Marine Corps and and
boot camp is everybody thinks it's like
Hands-On like you know you're gonna get
beat they're gonna put me like
physically physically yeah I mean and
you learn there that you know you don't
have to hit them to hurt them
you know I mean it's a one armed
distance nothing has changed if if you
need to put your hands on somebody then
you've lost leadership you know what I
mean if you have to go to the physical
force uh but you know just in your
mannerism and the shock and awe of Just
The Voice uh can just intimidate uh
people is mainly is your voice the Smoky
uh brings a lot to bear and then just
your physical fitness level uh you know
I mean because as a recruit you're like
this this guy like sweat like this guy
doesn't get tired I mean he these these
guys are just animals uh and and it is
it's it's a lot of it's a lot of hard
work it's a lot of long hours
um but it is it is very rewarding uh
when when you get the the recruits of
coming and it's and it's fun because now
you're like a live character on Saturday
Night Live I mean some of the stuff
that's why you got the big Smokey it's
so you can drop it so they can't see you
laughing because I mean some of the
stuff that you see that recruits do you
know I was like yeah I'd be with some of
the other hats because that's what you
call a DI hat you know you'd be with one
of their hats was like dude there's no
way I was this stupid when I was here
and you're like yeah you were you were
just as dumb as these kids are that are
coming in and they just do funny they do
funny stuff
and then as as a drill instructor when
when you get these kids on the yellow
Footprints and then in a three-month
period when their parents come down for
graduation and you're marching them up
there and it's parents day Thursday
afternoon at Paris Island and and all
the parents are excited to see their
kids excuse me and uh
when the parents have to come over and
ask you like which one's mine
you know what I mean you're kind of
looking at them like dude you've had
that kid for like 18 years and you don't
know which one's yours you know the
transformation when they get to go out
with their parents the drill instructors
get to meet the parents that night uh
when they bring the kids back to the
squad Bay and the parents are just like
how did you do this in three months he's
saying yes sir yes ma'am he's holding
doors open like he's sitting up straight
at the table you know what I mean like
what you all did to this to our son is
just incredible it's a great weight loss
program you know what I mean like folks
show up you know what I mean they look
like a sea bag with lips chewed up
bubble gum and you know what I mean
three months later they're fighting lava
monsters I mean they look like they're
you know straight out of 300 uh and so
that that's very rewarding of seeing
some of those uh some of those kids uh
just and you know in the Marine Corps
man we then we're going to put that
emblem on them for the rest of their
life I mean they've they've joined a
great Institution uh you know once a
marine always a marine you know we're
going to bring the families in we're
gonna mom dad they're gonna buy the
t-shirts the hats they're gonna fly the
flags uh the Marine Corps does a in my
opinion we do a really good job of
bringing in the entire family like you
know I mean you'll see the stickers on
the backs of cars my son's a U.S marine
my daughter's a U.S marine I mean we
might you know we got my grandson I mean
we bring in the whole family uh to
support that kid while he's you know
service to Country which is huge when
when you're a drill instructor or you're
a drill instructor School are they
talking you through sort of like the
psychological why behind this aspect of
training or this aspect to treatment I
for instance when I went to OCS you know
I had Marine Corps drill instructor
awesome guy um awesome Journal
instructor but at some point he he told
us stuff at the end you know and it was
I honestly I think I was asking a lot of
of questions because I wanted to
understand better but for instance when
you get to OCS you can't look at your
food you you have to they call it
squaring your meals and I was like hey
what why are we doing that and he goes
well that comes from when we when we
used to just train Pilots they had to
learn to use their peripheral vision so
they could see their instruments while
they're looking around okay that makes
sense hey why do we got to yell of you
because you got to speak in a ballistic
tone which means you got to yell
everything I'm like what's the reason
behind that he says well you know we get
these young ensigns in here that are
going to go on be be on board a ship
they're gonna be on the bridge and
they're gonna have to give orders on the
bridge in a simple clear concise manner
they can't be hesitant they gotta think
before they say but then they gotta say
it with a commanding voice so that
people actually hear them and then can
execute
so there's things going on that there's
a pragmatic reason behind but did they
ever break that down for you for
instance you know you can go watch on
YouTube you can go watch like the
welcome aboard uh it's not like the
first night but maybe it's the second
day where the Marines they have a very
uh pre-planned script that they're
saying about you know this is the Marine
Corps this is what we're doing do they
break stuff down at a at a at a
psychological level for you
because what you just said about the
Marine Corps doing it very well I mean I
don't know if there's anyone that does
it better than the Marine Corps I mean
in the world I don't know if there's any
group that has a stronger culture than
the Marine Corps that that takes normal
human beings from literally everywhere
and every strata of the United States of
America and sometimes other parts of the
world and turns them into this cohesive
unit
I don't know if there's anybody that
does it better but do they break it down
do they say hey here's the reason why we
do this right here like even basic SEAL
training
you know they're like oh what is hell
week for what is it for and there's
people that can answer that question
well here's what's going to happen you
know this is what's you're gonna you're
gonna have guys that are gonna quit on
the second day and those are the people
that blah blah and they've done all this
sort of psychological background on it
is there anything like that at the when
you when you become a Marine Corps drill
instructor that you understand the why
or is it just this is what we know works
yeah a lot of it has to do with this is
this is what works uh but at the same
time everything is done like you said
that you have squaring your meals like
everything is for a reason uh and it's
also you know the when we hand this
recruit over to this you know
commissioned officer it's instant
obedience to orders
like I mean these guys they're I mean
they do it better uh than anybody uh for
instance obedience but when you talk
about like uh the psychological aspect
so I was also I was a swim hat so I was
a Marine combat instructor water
survival so I was a uh a swim instructor
basically for the Marine Corps and you
know
because of the the kids that we recruit
like myself they can't put that Maureen
has something to do with Aquatics in it
for some reason uh you know I mean like
the recruiters don't like let them know
that hey when you get down there you you
got to swim
yeah I mean we get like you said I mean
we get kids from all over the planet
that have never the largest body of
water they've ever seen is the the pool
tank at Parris Island South Carolina I
mean they've never been in a body of
water that big
and we don't ask them if they can swim
like nobody's you know the drill
instructor doesn't come out hey anybody
not swim you can stand over here to the
side we just you know strap their gear
on them you know what I mean so give
them a rifle put a helmet on them
they're wearing their boots and they're
all like you know A to B right next to
the the 10-foot Tower and we're gonna
give them the the swim brief and we're
going to take them up on the 10-foot
Tower and ask them to take a 30 inch
step and do the deep end and swim 25
meters and when you're sitting there
look you know who the recruits are that
can't swim because they're probably
looking around going is anybody going to
ask like nobody there is not going to
ask and when you look at it we just want
to see if if they're going to step if
they can overcome fear
you know if an individual can't overcome
the fear or trust I mean there's a drill
instructor in the water waiting for you
like no one has drowned in this trend
like it's you know it's the instructors
that are there very professional very
well run
and when you see this this young man or
young woman you know what I mean that
mouths the tower that knows that they
can't swim a day in their life and but
they're gonna trust the instructors and
and the Marine Corps that we're going to
take care of you they just have to step
30 inch step they hit the water they
come up you know they're throwing up
stuff from the third grade they got snot
coming out they're straight to the they
don't even make it even close to
swimming at all they're just a rock in
the water we take them over to the side
we strip them all the way down until
they're you know their uh their PT
shorts and we take them down to the to
the shallow end and we teach them how to
swim
you know I mean it's a life skill uh and
you know there's nothing greater than
when you're you know because and it's
not necessarily you know maybe their
parents just
we don't know their background how they
were raised like for me I I don't
remember learning how to swim I could
just swim uh you know a lot of those
kids just don't have that Advantage uh
and we take them down there to the to
the shallow end of the pool and we teach
them the survival strokes and in a
couple of weeks you know like if they've
got different training they've got to
come back to the pool uh and do
remediation until we can get them to
pass and they can swim when you see the
confidence level in a kid now that he
can like swim and he passed that I mean
this guy's gonna go through brick walls
his fear is gone you know there's
nothing this kid cannot accomplish now I
mean it's just amazing you could see it
in them I mean you know if you've ever
like seen someone they accomplish
something just of a small task of like
swimming 25 meters like it's really not
that big of a deal but to that kid huge
life-changing event
how often what's the attrition rate of
Marine Corps boot camp
yeah how many guys would you lose you
know in a what what are you in charge of
there a platoon yeah so you gotta
platoon so you know depending on the
time of the year you might have you know
between 50 to 70 kids that are in a
platoon and you might lose 15 to 20 of
them uh but a lot of them you know it's
injuries so they're going to get really
sold out yeah they're just going to get
recycled and rolled uh they go to what
like if you come in like uh you know
when you first get down there you know
and it's no offense to recruiters or
anything like that but you know the kids
are supposed to be able to have
completed a somewhat of a physical test
prior to coming so they can at least
like pull themselves up out of a wet
paper bag at least like once before they
get there uh you know it's that whole
preparation thing and and some of the
kids you know we send them to PCP
physical conditioning platoon because
some of them show up and they're just
not not really prepared and when you
kind of look at that it's not really the
kid
you know the kid just read a pamphlet
you know what I mean he wants to come in
and that's somebody's son or daughter uh
you know I mean that they think that's
the greatest thing since sliced bread
and you know to be a marine I mean you
only got to do three Pull-Ups
I mean you only got to run three miles
in 28 minutes I mean it's not like we're
we're banging it you know what I mean of
like something that's just like
incredibly difficult but to some people
three pull-ups is that's the most
they've ever done in their life and uh
so you know we've got those we've got
medical Rehabilitation platoon uh so if
the guys get rolled back uh it's very
rare you know I mean like you can try to
drop I mean we do drop kids it gets sent
off the island and it's just because
they're just not conforming what about
just straight quitters like it's cold or
it's hot or it's too far
you're going to send them down
everybody's got like a series Commander
so you have an officer to kind of keep a
look over what's happening in cell block
uh you know what I mean and they have to
go down and they'll get an interview
with that uh you know a marine Captain
uh he's a series Commander and he's
going to try to talk that kid into
staying like hey you know what man the
Drone sharks really aren't that bad you
know I mean because it's all a numbers
game you know what I mean like in the
end the Marine Corps needs a certain
amount of numbers uh so he's going to
try to talk the kid back in and that's
like a lot of times with the platoon
Commander or the series commanders that
you have down there you're like
you gotta be me sir you're
gonna send this kid back man like God
you know this guy is just this kid's
incredible
and he's just like you just you know
work with him you know what I mean just
you know leadership challenge I hate
that you know what I mean like that's
the last thing I need in the middle of
boot camp was my leadership challenge
but in the end I mean you know they're
they're for the most part one when you
look at it they're joining the United
States Marine Corps so you look across
America like who else is joining you
know what I mean so at least the kid the
sign on a dotted line and he's going to
come and provide service to his country
which is that's pretty incredible uh
just in in that aspect uh but some of
them just you know psychologically they
just they're not mentally tough enough
and they're going to do whatever it
takes to get off of that Island
and we're going to do whatever it takes
to help them get off of that Island you
know it's a it's a it's a lot of fun
um
but you know the rifle range is usually
uh a pretty big deal you know every
brain's a Rifleman but you know we're
just looking you know Marksman how many
can get across the qualification lines
uh that kind of thing so the
Marksmanship package you know means the
two-week package down there I think it's
pretty good it's a pretty good
Marksmanship package that the Marine
Corps puts on uh you know for us
shooting them back at 500 with you know
green tip 556 that's not great ammo uh
it's a it's a pretty big accomplishment
uh and then you know just the the
aspects of when those kids uh graduate
from Paris Island uh you know I mean
they they look like they're ready to
just strap on the world uh and in a
three-month period you know they're
really not any tougher than they were
three months before when they got there
but their mindset is different uh I I
would say that that's probably the
biggest thing we just we changed their
mindset and hopefully we're making a
better product for America
uh when the kids go back home if they
get out hopefully we're putting a better
product back into society after serving
in the Marines and you know I would say
the majority we're doing a pretty good
job but I would say that for pretty much
all the armed services
the instant obedience to orders
when do you get uh the in the Marine
Corps you know Marine Corps was like we
already talked about gray and the
enlightenment the second Enlightenment
of the Marine Corps which is hey we want
people to think we want to have you know
Mission type orders and those kind of
things at what point do you go from all
right I'm a robot I'm going to obey the
orders that are given to me to hold on a
second boss here's what my thoughts are
yeah usually when you're getting the
non-commissioned officer when you step
into that team leader role you know what
I mean and then you're you know you're
reading assignment uh usually I don't
know if it's still to this day but you
know reading message to Garcia you know
what I mean just getting them on those
little interests of starting to to think
on their own uh you know what I mean and
not necessarily like everything has to
come from a book like everything very
set in stone you know what I mean so
when Al gray you know brings in these
you know the war fighting Publications
yeah it's starting to it's it's it's
kind of liberating
uh that you can now there's not a
problem with like questioning Authority
you it's basically you're not really
you're just asking why like what's the
why and it like why are we here why are
we doing it this way is it just because
you're telling me to uh you know what I
mean or is there actually some you know
method to the madness
um so I would say you know once you get
into that team leader kind of role in
NCO you know the non-commissioned
officer you know that's when you know
we're going to start you need to start
thinking on your own you need to start
taking charge it's not that instant
obedience to orders and you know if you
see something that's not right then you
know bring that up and and you shouldn't
be worried about the repercussions of of
questioning uh you know now there are
some that don't like to be questioned so
of course you know there there's that
aspect of it but that's in in any
organization any organization yes those
kind of
jerks
so you get done with what happens when
you get done with your time at drill
instructor where you go back to one sex
yep go right back uh first it didn't
want to have to buy new t-shirts and
stuff so I figured hey man yeah I called
the monitor let's go right back to first
time six Marines uh went back there uh
and now I'm I'm stepping into that like
platoon Sergeant kind of uh thing the
the Eli Tucker uh of my career uh and
that you mentioned to me one time uh we
were talking and you were like oh some
guys had a hard time taking off their di
hat
meaning they come from the drill field
where they're yelling and screaming and
expect to be treated basically like a
God and now they're back in a platoon
and it's like they keep acting like that
it can be a problem
yeah I mean no I don't want you know the
fellow drill instructors out there to
take offense but yeah the Marine drill
instructors you're just the lowest paid
actor
I mean it is an acting job uh you know I
mean you know you you're putting on a
it's a show
uh and someone would be like you know oh
I don't agree with that well if I'm like
the third hat you know I have a certain
way that they want me to act as a third
hat if I'm the heavy uh you know what I
mean the second hot the J of what's the
third hat the third hat you're like Nick
the new hat you just graduated from
school literally you might as well just
get a laundry number and stand with the
recruits because you don't know what
you're doing uh you know what I mean
it's you just run around and they're
like hey you know they'd be like hey dog
you you need to get louder and you need
to get faster you know everything that
you're doing is not fast enough it's not
loud enough it's not you know what I
mean so yeah so you're running around
and you're trying to be that that sand
flea to where you're just never letting
these kids get a break uh the the heavy
like the
he's the senior Green Belt uh in the
platoon and he's teaching him everything
drill teaching them Squad Bay procedures
you know what I mean he's very firm like
the heavy is the guy that's the most
experienced drill instructor he's the
one as a recruit you don't mess with
this guy he he knows the drill uh he's
very good at his job and then you got
like the senior drill instructor that
wears the black belt he's like Dad you
know what I mean like he comes in he
hands out mail he's nicer to you and
these are all stated roles yeah I mean
it's you know if if you're like the
third hat like the new guy and you're in
there like big daddy and the recruits
and handing out candy to them yeah
you're not going to go over well with
your peers that you know what I mean
they're they're gonna you know it's that
peer pressure of of how you're kind of
of what role you play uh in the platoon
um so you know some of the folks when
when you leave the drill field and you
go back to the fleet Marine Force some
of the folks that like they wear that
Smoky they want to they want to wear it
in the fleet and uh and a lot of folks
are like look dude we're not in boot
camp anymore uh and you know what I mean
you need to leave that hat on the island
um but you know when you do come back
and and
you know especially with the officers
and the senior enlisted uh as a as a
drill instructor you know what I mean I
mean you're bringing
um you're bringing a lot of of
experience uh you know what I mean and
work ethic back to the Battalion you
know my uh my oldest daughter she's
married to a marine he's infantry uh he
just finished his uh he was a DI uh you
know of course he calls me what should I
do next drellis Drucker man yeah I mean
and he knocked it out the park and now
he's back at Camp Lejeune uh and that's
the first thing I told him leave the
leave the Smoky you know at Paris Island
you know I mean there's just no place
for it that's not a that's not a
leadership style uh
you know nobody really responds well to
that uh other than Marine Corps recruits
in you know at Paris Island right that's
it that's it you know but and the funny
thing is is like you know after you've
been on the drill field and you don't
really remember all the recruits that
you've had just because there's just a
whole bunch of them so it's kind of hard
to like keep up
but some of them you end up like finding
out that like that that kid was in your
platoon and you go over to them and it's
like hey how come you didn't come over
and say anything you're wrong too
they're like dude I wasn't going to come
over and talk to you man like are you
you me like dude I'm scared to
death at you and it's just like just a
regular guy you know what I mean but
it's that that whole perception and you
know everybody still remembers their
Marine Journal instructors uh it's even
me my sergeant Williams uh was my senior
General child never forget that guy yeah
and he was motor T oddly enough my my
drill instructor I still remember in
officer candidate school and his last
name his Gunnery Sergeant seals
which is an interesting coincidence
right yeah yeah awesome guy awesome guy
so you get back to one six and now
you're now you're a platoon Sergeant is
that right yeah yeah I'm back I'm still
a sergeant uh so I was at E5 technically
you're supposed to be a uh a E6 uh to
get a platoon but you know they were
they were short on those guys so I I got
a platoon uh and this is what like 1997
or something like 96 yeah I finished
yeah I finished on the drill field in 95
uh and came over and right back into one
six uh in in 96.
um
and I was very excited to be back uh at
Camp Lejean not that I didn't have a
like a good time at person I had a
little bit it was a DI I had a little
run-in with a with one of the Battalion
commanders that was down there and he
thought it was a little overly
aggressive and you know it was you know
he he told me that you know let me tell
you what it's like to be a drill
instructor and I was like well when were
you a drill instructor sir that went
over like a fart in church you know what
I mean he didn't like that aspect of it
and uh so me and him didn't necessarily
see eye to eye so when I left Paris
Island they were like you know
please don't come back but it was a lot
of fun uh and then when I got back to
the fleet
um there was a lot of other guys that
you know the the drill instructor
Community is is very small and it's it's
pretty tight
uh and if and if you get back in uh one
of the company Gunnies his name was
Clifford happy he was a hat uh so when I
came in you know I just got more
opportunities uh just because I had that
experience of being a drill instructor
so they gave me a platoon uh which I was
super stoked with and it gave me a uh
platoon Commander uh his name Buck
Rollins uh his dad was Wayne Rollins uh
two star general Navy cross winner
Vietnam a great guy I've just attended
his funeral a few months back he was
buried in Arlington uh Buck Rollins and
I uh you know um somebody got Doug
zunbeck was there at the time I mean
that Battalion for some odd reason man
we had some like amazing second
lieutenants like that were just like you
didn't really see that many great guys
uh that were all in that Battalion from
pascoli to you know uh you know there
was a just a bunch of them Alfredo uh
was in there it was platoon commanders
uh that was my first experience of where
you know when you become up up as a
platoon Sergeant you get to spend more
time with platoon Commanders you know
before that you don't really hang out
with the officers like at all uh you
know what I mean but then you become
like uh you're a partner you know what I
mean you're gonna work this platoon
together uh and I had you know I was
very uh fortunate I had uh Buck Rollins
I had Doug zumbeck and I had Doug Olson
these guys were wearing your platoon
commanders yeah and I worked uh with
them right they were the platoon
Commander but it's my platoon
yeah yeah they just get to hang out yeah
we they say in the office about the
officers and the SEAL Teams is like they
rent we own yeah the officers are rent
we own yeah it's like my it's like the
chief you know the the e-dogs it's their
platoon the officers just you know he's
gonna be here for a little while but
this is our platoon yeah that's pretty
much the exact same thing it is in an
infantry pattai and it's it's the
platoon Sergeant it's you know like I
said I mean you know Eli Tucker had a
huge effect on me as a as a platoon
sergeant and you know coming in from the
the kids that were in apple tune uh and
you know I've stayed in in one six for
uh like three and a half years uh in the
Battalion did a couple of pumps I was
gonna say so you do a work up training
cycle and then go on deployment riding
ships on those deployments uh yeah uh
riding ships doing the work up uh we did
a med float uh which was uh which was
super cool uh we kind of got deployed
Earl I ended up over in uh Albania
Toronto Albania if you remember in like
the 97 time frame they were kind of
blowing embassies up around the uh so we
got the call I was with uh the 24th yeah
24th Mew and we've just finished up uh
doing work up
and we needed to they wanted us to go
into Toronto Albania uh so you know I
got the call at that time I had the uh
sniper platoon uh so I had the the
snipers I took uh 12 guys uh and you
know we jumped on c-130s up in uh Cherry
Point with an infantry rifle company uh
and they flew us over we did a refuel uh
I think it's Singapore landed in Italy
got on a 53 flew out on the ussi pan
with the 22nd mu got briefed in and we
were in country uh in Tron Albania after
they had evacuated the embassies out of
there uh and uh and that was uh we we
stayed over there for a couple of months
and so what were you doing what was your
mission uh just uh basically uh
uh run and the embassy was evacuated so
so it's empty yeah it's empty I mean so
you guys are basically doing Security on
the embassy yep to make sure it doesn't
get trashed or whatever or no one comes
in steals or yep uh and they I mean
they had a lot of a lot of other
agencies that were over there running
around uh you know uh it was some uh
Navy Seals were over there uh there was
a lot of stuff going on you know I mean
the overarching was Bosnia you know I
mean that whole region at the time uh it
was a it was a really good experience uh
you know especially for the younger guys
that were in the platoon uh the guys
that I uh had an apple tune uh even
still to this day I'm still in contact
with uh you know from uh those guys that
was uh that was a very special time
those three years at one six being in
that uh platoon Sergeant or what you
would call like Chief Scout kind of role
uh was just huge uh I learned more about
myself uh then uh you know with with
those folks and and just you know
they're relying on me uh you know what I
mean to to train educate them take care
of them uh it was it was a really a a
really special time in the Marine Corps
uh for that that time in service
when you went over there were you the
senior guy or did you have an officer we
had an officer company Commander uh
company Commander we had uh and then of
course the Mew had their some of their
Muse staff uh that was over there uh
Sean pascoli was a captain uh that was
over there I'm still uh friends with
Sean
um
uh those guys they had a a company kind
of reinforced so we had some guys that
were at the embassy we had some guys
that kind of stayed back and they were
at the housing complex he still had
State Department folks that were Milling
about the area uh and you know they're
just looking for for bad guys we did a
lot of time like watching we were
basically at snipers we were OverWatch
so you know we had albanians working
Gates stuff like that you know we would
hire them uh and then we would do the
OverWatch for them uh over at the
embassy was right next to the University
of Toronto uh so it was just a a lot of
observing a lot of the time observing
but it was the the same experience for
those guys that I got when I was in went
to Panama you know when the issue out
the live ammo it's just a different game
you know I mean even though nothing
eventful which I'm thankful for took
place while we were over there uh
because you know the only thing that
would come in in the back of my mind
when I think of like being at an embassy
is Beirut yeah uh you know when you're
just blowing stuff up that's not
necessarily Warfare anymore uh yeah
that's terrorist activities uh that's a
you know and you know when you when you
think of the events of a of an infantry
company
you know in a Barracks you know you
can't help but think of Beirut
um so but luckily we learned from that
the company Commander was there like we
were very well dispersed nobody was
going to be in one you know single point
of failure uh the OverWatch on the gates
the guards I mean it was there wasn't
you know the rules of engagement you
know I I you know of what they had to
deal with at Beirut completely different
so obviously you know we were a learning
organization of we're not going to let
this kind of happen again which was
which was really cool uh for those guys
to to kind of go through that experience
uh and then you know once everything was
over and the you know the threats were
were pretty much eliminated and gone
they brought the embassy back Ambassador
comes back in and I mean people go to
Toronto Albania on vacation I mean which
is kind of kind of funny uh you know
even like you know people go to Panama
now it's a great vacation spot uh you
know when I was there I never thought
that like who would want to come to
Toronto Albania you know what I mean but
they were super nice people
uh you know beautiful part of the world
but just different uh than us
then what came after that uh after that
I got I went I attended uh up at
Quantico I attended the advance they
used to have an advanced sniper School
uh up at Quantico so I went through the
advanced cyber school prior to that
deployment uh and the staff at cic uh
that was up there uh Bill Norton his
name we call him Max Max is uh he asked
me if I wanted to come back up to be an
instructor at Quantico after that next
deployment of course you know I was like
yeah yeah uh you know I mean going up to
Quantico so he brought me up there as an
instructor when I got done so I was an
instructor at uh Quantico I took over as
the chief instructor for the schoolhouse
up at Quantico which was I mean it's a
it was tons of fun it just I mean you
know everybody that shows up I mean
sniper's cool because they do the we do
the basic course uh you do the advanced
course and then you do what's called the
sniper employment officer course so the
guys that are going to be like in charge
of sniper platoon we put them through
like a sniper employment package uh
two-week course kind of the thing at
Quantico and I mean it was just a it was
a lot of fun uh just every day I mean
the instructors the students uh it's
just a lot of fun it's a great package
yeah I mean the stocking exercises is
like fun you know I mean that's like a
people should pay money to go do that uh
and and then just the you know bury your
ass in brass I mean you're gonna shoot a
lot of ammo uh you know so
uh and and as an instructor at that
level uh you know I was the chief
instructor I expected that all the
instructors on the Cadre should be able
to perform any of the skill sets at any
given time
365 days you know when the when the kids
would come in to run the physical
fitness test I expected the instructors
out there running right along with the
students uh you know that kind of an
aspect of uh you know even though we've
got mine you know a lot of times people
you know I got mine let's make it harder
for the next guy yeah I mean the
training schedule alone is hard enough
you don't have to how long is the how
long is the sniper course it's like 12
weeks that's freaking no joke yeah I
mean it's uh is that the sniper course
for the whole Marine Corps that's it
well we've got Quantico you've got Camp
Lejeune you got Pendleton so right up
here Pendleton they they run the basic
course four times a year and how long is
the basic course it's the 12-week okay
uh and then they they got rid of the
advanced course matter of fact they got
rid of the basic like it's all and I'm
sure it's better like better now than
whatever we were doing uh you know
because uh we were still back in the
probably in the Hathcock days you know
what I mean of the the white feather you
know the Chuck mulhaney you know we're
gonna you know this stalking and uh
which stalking is a uh I would say
stalking is it's patrolling it's just on
the ground it's a different perspective
uh you know stalking you learn so much
from just laying with your face sucking
the Earth of what we call skull dragon
you might be the first person that I've
heard say stalking was fun like most
guys that go through the SEAL Sniper
course they're like
stalking is not fun I I would say
because it's kind of it's a game yeah
you know you're going up against a guy
that's a trained Observer and they're on
glass
and the ability for you to be able to
come in to you know 200 yards you know
what I mean get two rounds off
undetected and stalk out yeah it's
amazing I mean it's a it's just it's
amazing of the ability to hide blend and
deceive uh is is pretty cool and if you
understand how that all works I mean you
don't even need a ghillie suit you could
be literally naked and and stalk if you
understand how uh you know this the
stalking of blending backdrop you know
the cover uh so it was it was a lot of
fun plus you just get a lot of really
good Marines uh we used to get Advanced
course we'd have Navy Seals come through
we'd have Army Rangers come through up
there uh British royal Commando we
actually have a British role on the
staff at Quantico we have a really good
relationship with the Brits
um so it's just a you know it's a it's a
fun time when you've got like 24 great
Americans uh that just want to shoot
bolt guns uh you know what I mean and
look through glass it's just a fun time
uh everybody's there with a with a
purpose like there's not you know the
leadership aspect is kind of gone you
don't necessarily you lead by example uh
you know I mean like when I'm looking at
an instructor you know if I walk in on
training day one and the instructor
looks like a sea bag with lips and the
first thing he's going to tell me how he
used to be a badass you know what I mean
dude you're 33 years old yeah you know
what I mean like nobody's old here you
know what I mean uh you know but in that
military you think of Malachi's an old
man you know what I mean he's 34. you
know what I mean like you should be in
the Prime in your 30s uh so you know I
always like that about the the snipers
and even the reconnaissance school
that's up the road up here I'm sure it's
the same with buds I mean the
instructors that are there you know
you're just looking at them and I mean
they just they look the part they better
yeah yeah I mean and they can do
anything that they're asking
the student to do
which is is a super cool way of that
that leadership and then holding
yourself accountable to be to being able
to uh to perform at any given time yeah
so where are you when September 11th
happens is this where you're at is this
where you're stationed When September
11th happens yep I'm up at uh Quantico
that's why I call it the world changed
in nine miles uh we got the students off
and I went there's a loop uh up at
Quantico over where sniper school is you
can run over by when you say you've got
the students off what do you mean you
cut a moose no no like they're just you
know they get them in in the morning
they're going to go to the reins they're
going to do an observation exercise
they're going to do you know I mean
there's another instructor that has them
because you know when on the instructor
Contra you kind of have to manage your
time of you know obviously I had to be
there when the students are there as the
chief instructor and then we got to get
the day going if I'm on the platform
first or if I'm so and I always enjoy
getting a a run-in you know throughout
the day get a chance to work out go to
the pool do something so that that day
on September 11th we got you know we got
students on Deck uh we get them off and
going and and I take off over towards
the FBI Academy so I'm right over there
by the FBI Academy and and the basic
school and there's a Nine Mile Loop that
goes around and I I take off I let the
guys know hey man I'm gonna go for a run
I'm going to run the loop and they know
exactly where I'm going
and uh so I'm I'm off and running and as
I'm making my way in and around over by
what they they have uh called uh Lake
lunga that's over at Quantico next to
the FBI Academy and I'm coming in and
I'm seeing like a lot of aircraft like
flying around yeah the FBI always has
like stuff going on they got the hostage
rescue team that's there as well
uh but then it's just like aircraft like
kilos yeah hilos and stuff like it's a
lot of activity which is that but then
all the black vehicles are just leaving
the FBI compound and yeah because you
gotta that's the funny thing about like
at Quantico that day before we used to
not have Gates you could literally drive
up I-95 and pull off the exit and drive
straight on to Range four with the
sniper students laying right there on
the Range and you didn't go through a
gate you didn't nobody checked your ID
card nothing there was just no Gates uh
and so I'm I'm running back and I'm
seeing all these vehicles fly out and by
the time I get back to the schoolhouse
it's kind of like you know I'm like what
the what the hell is going on and that's
when you know the pentagon's being hit
you know New York 911's being hit and
it's just like
it it's it's game on uh and the world
changed in nine nine miles I mean within
a Nine Mile Run man the world completely
changed we had sandbags Barracks I mean
their their man and Gates they're making
Gates I mean it was it was total Anarchy
uh in Quantico and as you can imagine I
mean being so close to the Pentagon uh
of them hitting the Pentagon they got
guys that are coming in you know they're
wanting to know like how can Marines
support and that that kind of was odd to
me that like we didn't have
authorization to go out to like help
uh you know what I mean like you got all
these marines you got all these folks
like why aren't Marines like you know
they bring the Marines in uh but then
you have to look at it as like the
event's over
like I mean they flew into the buildings
you know we're all thinking like what's
kind of next that was it that was the
big event
uh and you know after that then
everybody knew at that point in time
it's it's go time uh we're you know and
the Marines are you know Army I'm sure
with you guys with the teams like
everybody's watching thinking yeah you
know when are we going to deploy when
when's the first action that's going to
start coming in
um but yeah I was at uh I was at
Quantico
so then what what happens after that
uh well I had uh met a couple of guys
um through being up there at uh sniper
School uh and there was uh there was a
certain unit
um and I was hoping to get uh selection
into that it's kind of one of the guys
recommended me uh so I went in I went
through recommendations and um and with
that they needed a place for me to kind
of hang out uh and a weight selection
like in the national capital region so
uh uh John Allen uh was the coming on
amid shipment at the Naval Academy and I
had I'd known him from down in the six
Marines and you know John Allen was like
yeah yeah I'll take JD bring him up to
the naval academy and of course I was
like yeah I'm going to the Naval Academy
like I'd I'd never been to Annapolis
Maryland a day in my life I I didn't I
mean I knew the academy but like my
perception of a Naval Academy graduate
was Doug zembeck
like that's what I expected and then my
other guy that I worked with at sniper
school was John Bradley uh John Bradley
was a three-time national boxing champ
at the Academy his call sign was big
people uh it was half black half German
I mean the dude was like Rambo you know
what I mean he's I'm still really good
friends with John Brown he's a great
human being but you know I used to make
fun of them like you know because he'd
wear like Navy boxing and you know and
of course Doug was a Navy wrestler and I
was like dude I want my tax paying
dollars back there's no way you guys
went to the Naval Academy but that's my
perception of the Naval Academy you know
the officers that that I had dealt with
were they come out of the Naval Academy
they were they were top-notch
um so that was that was my perception
going in
uh I can remember when when I when I
went up to check into the Naval Academy
again I didn't know where it was I just
knew it was in Annapolis so I'm driving
around Annapolis I'd get over top of the
Severn bridge and I'm I'm looking down
but I think it's like it looks like the
state capitol
yeah and there's like two women that are
walking across the bridge and I'm like
excuse me ladies do you guys like know
where the Naval Academy is and they're
laughing like dude that's it I was like
wow like that's next level like I mean
it's it's impressive uh so I went down
and and uh and checked in uh to the
economy and you know John Allen and at
first I really didn't have a job for me
to do because like the the midshipmen
had already started and I really didn't
know like what I was getting into like I
didn't know like what they do at the
Naval Academy and your anticipation is
that you're waiting to go to selection
for a special Mission Unit and you're
going to be there for six months or
something yeah and then you'll roll out
yep that that's my mindset and and you
know and and John Allen uh you know
great guy Wicked smart I was super
excited because the library at the Naval
Academy is off the chain I mean like
it's off the chain and I you know I mean
I I love a library
uh you know what I mean I get the so I
mean there's a lot of history up there I
mean Tecumseh Court you know what I mean
like they got Tecumseh you know what I
mean and uh so it was it was a a bit of
a root of Awakening like so the first
morning kind of like you know this
morning I got up you know I'm gonna go
for a run so that's how I like to like
get myself like situational awareness of
like Get orientated is is run so I'll
run around so I'm running around
Annapolis looking at the town and stuff
and I make my way back in and I'm on
Tecumseh Court and as I'm into Tecumseh
Court I'm standing there I'm looking I
mean they got like monuments like all
over the place I mean the Chapels there
it's pretty banging they got like a
bunch of different poles and they got
Tecumseh and and I'm looking at the
company mixing it out like there's this
Navy officer
he's like hey you know hey were you
doing I wasn't wearing anything that
said Marines on it and he's like hey
you're not allowed to be out here in PT
gear
I was like
am I not on a military installation like
with the Navy we don't like to PT and
you don't want us to say like it was
like it was odd like the rules that they
had there uh at the Academy and and you
know John Allen sent me over with the
football team where couldn't you be with
that with PT uniform on I don't know
they didn't like PT gear being out there
in Tecumseh Court like where they chose
specifically to come support yeah it's
like a I guess it's a ceremonial area
like you're supposed to be like in the
Marine Corps like everywhere is a PT
area you know what I mean like weekend
PT wherever you want you know what I
mean like I've never been told don't be
out in front of people in this area in
PT gear uh so that was kind of odd and
then you know so I went over with the
football team
uh because at first I was like oh you
know college football and
I asked the coaches like hey is this
like open practice is it cool if I watch
you know I mean they're like yeah dude
you know I mean you can come over and
watch and it was coach Paul Johnson at
the time uh and the strength coach and
stuff and I went over there and uh you
know the kids on the on the football
team uh I would say
um yeah I felt out of place at the Naval
Academy
like like I didn't belong like there's
no Marines in the brochure and there's
definitely no Marine Gunnies in the
brochure uh there were other Gunnies
that were there but like you said I mean
I was there I I just come from sniper
school I have a I had a different
Outlook
uh than a lot of the other folks uh
and so when I was over there like the
the midshipman on the football team like
they they immediately came over and
started talking to me asking me you know
like hey who are you what are you doing
because I wasn't in uniform and I was
like yeah hey I'm gunny and that's how I
introduced myself to like coach Paul
Johnson and I mean I think like because
the coaches aren't military
so I think they thought like my first
name was gunny
and still to this day they call me gunny
you know which I don't care uh you know
what I mean it's uh and the football
players and man I got to stand out there
and watch some of these kids that are
going to compete on division one level
uh and they join the the academy with
not really a lot of hopes of going to
the NFL
um but the the kids on the team uh and
and the athletes that are there at the
Academy the midshipmen are I mean
they're just they are really good people
uh you know there I look at them just
like they join them they just read a
different brochure than I did and
obviously scored like way higher on the
SAT because I never took that test uh
you know what I mean but they were like
really really good kids uh at the
Academy
um
and uh I I just had a phenomenal uh
experience being there with the the
midshipmen uh they they welcomed me with
open arms the midship I had more fun so
what job did you actually get assigned I
ended up being a senior enlisted advisor
for 30th company uh and so there's how
many companies are there's 30. okay yeah
and obviously 30th company had like a
bad rap before I got there you know what
I mean so they had them living on zero
deck right next to the battle the
Battalion officer well the Battalion
officer was a guy named Alan eschbach uh
and Alan eschbach great guy I went to
Millersville State uh up in Pennsylvania
ran cross country and he was a Navy
captain and I had never really been
around a Navy Captain you know I mean
not a lot of them you know that I didn't
interact with the ship's Captain when I
was a boy he didn't come down to cell
block and hang out and slap Spades uh
you know so uh Alan eschbach he'd see me
up running you know what I mean and he
he ran cross country he was a surface
Warfare officer he had the Arleigh Burke
uh you know he ended up taking over the
San Jacinto uh and you know I I already
kind of mentioned my kind of like being
a ship's Captain has got to be like a
cool job well so Allen started coming
running with me in the morning
and and he lived right there on the yard
and like these these Battalion officers
the houses that they get on the Naval
Academy are pretty banging and he would
have me over for dinner and stuff I got
to know his wife his kids I mean he was
just a super nice guy and uh and so I
ended up having this relationship with
this this Navy this Navy captain and he
was just a great guy we'd be really good
friends and we're still friends to this
day uh and he was about ready to roll
out to go take over the USS San Jack and
as he was leaving we were getting a new
Battalion officer coming in and he's
like hey he's like JD is there which was
kind of cool that Captain would call me
JD
um and and he was like hey he's like uh
is there anything I can do for you like
before I leave and I was like yeah can
you move 30th company up to eight four
so it's the highest point at the Navy
nobody goes to 8-4 plus the midshipmen
that have to walk the class every day
they're going to have to walk all the
way to eight four like every single day
and you have the midshipmen have to chop
they call that chopping where they like
run and say go Navy beat Army and did
you see him when you were up there
speaking like they do this is that
punishment or is that just standard
operating position just standard
operating proceeds like I didn't know
what they were doing like wait just when
you're going from class to class every
time you square a corner or something
you got to say like go on a go Navy beat
Army stuff like that yeah and they call
it chopping so it's like they're running
and they're in dress shoes which makes
absolutely no sense but
and they're calling it chopping and I'm
like interesting
you know what I mean go Navy beat Army
okay I got it so that's a lot of
chopping to get up to the top of eight
four you know what I mean so and then I
knew nobody would come visit me
people are just lazy you know what I
mean like nobody's gonna come up to
eight four I'm gonna live up on 8-4 it's
going to be great uh so eight four is a
building yeah eight four it's like
Bancroft Hall like when you saw Bancroft
I was all the way in the very back uh so
I was the farthest away from Tecumseh
Court as possible and I was the closest
to the football locker as possible and
you know I mean the uh
the athletes and the and being assigned
up there
um I it was a great place to be uh as a
as a senior enlisted
um because like I'm not teaching these
kids like if you're an officer and you
got to get like I was there with Randall
uh Lieutenant Randall was there uh you
know I mean he was a company officer and
like company officers have to like teach
stuff like they got to go over to
Academia and teach doubly or they got it
like do stuff I'm not teaching double e
you know what I mean and you know
they're not gonna all I got to do is
like just hang out like a full-time
Mentor yeah and hang out and just be
there for the kids if they need anything
and and uh and I worked with the Navy
Lieutenant great guy uh it was a lot of
fun but I mean so when the kids go to
class it's like you got nothing to do
but you've got an Olympic pool you've
got batting cages you've got football
cages you got an indoor track you got a
Sailing Center you got soccer fields you
got a rifle team you got like dude I
didn't it was Camp I mean I literally it
was I was back at Camp except like they
have like the best facilities like known
to man I'd go out and throw BP for the
base baseball I go out and do you know
batting practice and I just get to know
the kids uh you know they were going
through and if they had questions about
you know joining the Marine Corps and
stuff like that and then especially with
the football team uh the one thing that
I learned there is like you know the
football players don't have to do like
the the Friday parades and they get out
of a lot of other stuff they do their
own meals and stuff and I think that you
know there's a lot of folks that don't
understand what it takes to compete at
division one level football
uh you know what I mean like do other
athletes get out of that stuff too no
not like football gets out uh and I
wouldn't really what about the wrestlers
no
soccer players no so it's just football
yeah they I mean the other like the
other sports teams if they've got a game
they'll get out of something but like
football is is looked at I mean
is looked at different uh at the Academy
and then you're hiring a coach like
coach Paul Johnson I mean he came from
Georgia Tech great guy he's the highest
paid guy in the Navy
like this dude makes more than the CNO
this is like the head coach at army
makes more than the chief of staff of
the army which kind of puts stuff into
perspective you know what I mean like
well wait a minute man I can make more
money being the head coach at Navy than
the CNO you know what I mean like like
this dude's driving a nuclear submarine
you know what I mean but the football
coach and it's just like you know Ken
niamat that's there right now great guy
he was an o-line coach when I was there
and the coach is just doing a job they
get hired to do a job compete at the
division one level pack the stands and
the football team because of the the
amount of money that they make you know
at stadiums ticket sales stuff like that
pays for a lot of the other sports
programs to be able to take place yeah
it's got to be recruiting too they
probably take recruiting budgets
probably paying that coach's salary yeah
so uh and the coaches are great and the
kids that they get on that football team
I mean you know people are like oh they
get out of the Friday afternoon heard
across the grass you know what I mean
like really they're up at five o'clock
in the morning they got to watch films
they got Apes that got practice they got
weights they got I mean they have to
perform you know what I mean on Saturday
you know their weekends their
thanksgivings if they get a bowl game
you know what they sacrifice to be able
to play division one football and then
go serve their country just like
everybody else so they're just there on
a different aspect
I think some of the folks just don't
they don't look at it that way but the
student athletes at the Academy are
phenomenal they're just one the team
players you know what I mean like if if
you leave a team sport uh from the
academy and and join the Marine Corps
it's a very easy transition
yeah because you're just leaving one
team and you're just joining another
team
uh and the the athletes transition
really well into the Marine Corps
um and you know I just think that the
kids that were on the team I mean they I
had like a lot of fun uh with those kids
and then you know some of them when they
select Marines at the end of the year
you got like o-line guys you got
defensive line guys that have never run
farther than 100 yards in their life and
now it's the end of football season and
oh hey by the way you got to meet height
and weight standards by May yeah that's
that's hard for some of the guys that go
to buds you know they got to like
totally change their physique like they
got to become a different kind of human
being like I got one friend that was uh
at the Naval Academy played football and
I don't say his nickname but he's a big
guy and even when I know him he's a big
guy like a like a big guy but apparently
I didn't know him when he played
football but he had to like change
who he was as a human being to get from
playing whatever freaking lineman at the
Naval Academy to go and run you know 12
miles and four miles and six miles you
know like all that running it's just a
totally you're a different human
yeah so that's a challenge yeah and then
you got to teach them how to run
like you know it's some of them just
they don't I mean there's a big
difference between sprinting 100 yards
and running three miles yeah and then oh
by the way you're gonna go to TBS
you know what I mean especially if they
go to Marines but even if they're if
they're going you know surface Warfare
or going there I mean that's a big
transition uh for a lot of those guys uh
that are out there and you know and I
would run them in a mile and a half the
only thing that I could do my biggest
shock when I was at the academy uh was
like I was talking to some of the uh
midship one of them is uh it was Jason
Copeland he's a Marine lieutenant
colonel now he's Amsterdam Commander
great human being uh so Jason I was like
hey what's what do you guys got going on
tomorrow morning like you guys got your
physical fitness test I heard because I
didn't know like what these kids did
and he's like yeah we'll meet out by the
uh by the Farragut and you know the PT
Department takes care of of the the
physical fitness test and they run the
PRT and I was like oh yeah what is it
you know what I mean okay well we do you
know push-ups setups and then we do a
mile and a half run I was like okay
that's cool what time do you go I I'd
like to come out
well most of the staff there like it's
early in the morning like why why are
you gunny why are you you don't have to
go I was like well I know I don't have
to go
but I should go and run with the kids
so I I showed up and they do each
Battalion so there's six battalions and
each Battalion gets a day and they show
up and there's you know five battalions
and or five companies in each Battalion
they're gonna run five physical
Readiness tests
so I I show up and and you know they're
only going to run a mile and a half
so you know so for me I was like well
you know I asked the PE guy like do you
care if I like run with them am I
allowed to run with them
you know what I mean like I'll do a 10
30 Pace just run along and you know what
I mean kind of give the kids a an
earmark of like where I'm at because I
used to do that at Cyber School like if
I'd run the three mile and I'm like hey
I'm gonna run right at a of what is a 20
30. pace so for three miles I'm gonna
run it in 20 minutes and 30 seconds
because that's worth 85 points so if you
see JD he's worth 85 points if you're in
front of me you know because it's all
the numbers game if you're not good at
pull-ups you better Bank It On the Run
if you're not you know what I mean so
it's your strength and weaknesses so I
was like you know and I was like okay
this is the Naval Academy like it's only
a mile and a half you got to do it in 10
30. that's a seven minute pace man it's
pretty easy
so as I'm out there and I'm watching the
kids and I'm running along with them you
know kind of going along and I'm like
hey where where are these guys going
like they're falling out like where it's
only a mile and a half and they're
falling out I was just like well they
they failed like they didn't pass the
run so I go over to the PE department
and I'm kind of like so what happens to
these kids man they like pack their
they done and they're like bro no
remediate you know what I mean they're
going to remediate the hell out of them
uh and and I always thought like well
this is something that I could
help out
you know I can I can come out and run
with these kids and uh so I used to go
run when they do the prts for the for
the Brigade of midshipman I would run 30
of them back to back at a 10 30 pace
and I was like yeah only five a day
though oh okay so you know I mean it's
really not that hard it's only like
eight eight and a half miles you know
what I mean and for me I'm not a runner
I just have a running problem you know
what I mean so for me like that that
seven minute pace was you know it's a
pretty good workout for me I'd come out
and I would run with the kids and kind
of you know what I mean and you know
kind of help them and push them like if
they're going to fall back this is
something that I can actually you know
help out with the Naval Academy if
there's a kid struggling with a mile and
a half I can help him out and get him to
pass so that yeah because once he goes
to the fleet and he's in the Navy that's
not a required 10 30 he's not a
requirement in the fleet it's just the
Naval Academy requirement for officers
uh so but hopefully yeah so uh I used to
do that uh with the kids and I would get
excited uh you know what I mean to go
out and run the the prts uh with them at
shipment because I mean it was
hysterical uh just you know watching
them for that a mile and a half how is
the the psychological molding of the
guys or their people or the kids that
are going to the Naval Academy compared
to what you saw at boot camp
well it's uh
yeah there's there it's it's the country
club uh yeah I would say it's kind of
like being a Catholic school and you're
just a nun yeah you know what I mean
you're a nun
uh yeah it's it's it's not yeah it's
night and day you know they do uh bleep
summer uh that's there but it's the it's
the the upper class are kind of run and
pleap summer and they do I mean they do
a pretty good job but they're not drill
instructors yeah I mean they're not
smoking it out they're not you know that
the shock and awe isn't as much but uh
they they do they do a pretty good job
with them at uh at plebe summer and you
know and being a plea but the Naval
Academy to me was like dude that just
does not look like fun yeah it looks
awful like at all one I gotta say go
Navy beat Army and chop around the place
in my dress shoes uh you know I know
Liberty I don't get to really do
anything I I you know uh the knowledge
that they push on those kids there
though and the in the education level is
phenomenal and then I would say like the
the camaraderie of the of each class uh
is just it's outstanding uh with the
Naval Academy of bringing those kids
together you know sharing and in this in
the suffering together uh all four years
at the academy uh but it is a it's a
great institution and they put out a a
great product in my opinion uh probably
the the best to watch was uh
the ones that wanted to go special
Warfare Navy Seals uh that was the mo
while I was there uh you know uh Randall
was a lieutenant and he kind of ran that
uh pre-buds kind of selection processor
tight selection oh it is the most com I
mean he's got like a couple hundred kids
that want to be I mean there's only a
thousand of them yeah and a couple
hundred of them want to become a seal
yeah and there's like 15 billets yeah
like that 15 slots yeah and yeah I've
been it's always been cool uh I've done
during covet I did some
um some virtual training with the with
the Hamid shipment I've gone there live
it's been awesome to go up there live
and and just you know talk about
leadership from my perspective and
they're definitely stoked on it very
cool but yeah that competitiveness for
the seal billets in any whether you're
rot in any officer seal belts is
it's hard it's very very difficult
probably well because the recruiting
Because so many people want to go into
to that
job
and it's a rough job to get into yeah I
would say yeah uh but what those kids
would you know the thing that that I
learned while I was there was kind of
disappointing uh for me being a Marine
was the the Marine selection so you
would have like you know I mean let's
say you got 100 kids that put they want
to go Navy Seals as their number one
choice and then Marine ground is their
second and you would have marines that
were up on the yard going that's
yeah you know I mean if they're
not Marine first we don't want I'm like
these kids are going after like if if JD
was there yeah who wouldn't it's the
Naval Academy man like I mean they want
to go Navy SEAL they're gonna compete
for the hardest Billet going yeah
you know at least physically yeah that's
actually another way to look at it is
hey these guys want the hardest possible
job and they're trying to get in the
heart the the most selective thing so
they're taking the most selective thing
that's the seal Billet if they don't get
that yeah because that is horrible and I
had I've had a bunch of friends you know
that graduated from the Naval Academy
that had to make that call and it's so
hard I mean life didn't get selected out
of the Naval Academy Seth didn't get
sucked out of the main they both went to
you know a ship and it's a different
personality type that is going to be a
ship a swell there's a different human
it's a different type of mindset than
someone that's going to be some kind of
a land Soldier you know whether it's a
marine or a special operations guy it's
a different type of mindset you have to
have and so
both I forget I have to ask wife again
but you know he got told the same thing
he's like hey there's it's it's a waste
to put Marine Corps after seals because
you're just not going to get taken and
life you know would have loved if he
didn't make it in the seals but you know
he probably would have gotten picked up
for the Marine Corps and probably would
have never joined the SEAL Teams and the
Marine Corps would have had a cool
officer
yeah I mean that's that's kind of like I
knew a lot of these kids like they would
come out and like because I would run
every morning at five
you know what I mean so I'd go run and
uh I ran a lot like they had a marathon
team that was there at the Academy so I
became like the O rep for them so like
the Naval Academy would like fly us
around so we were doing Chicago we're
doing Boston we're doing Disney uh you
know what I mean like with the
midshipmen and and you know and if they
knew that like midshipman can't leave
the yard but if they're running with me
then they're allowed to just say I'm
with gunny you know what I mean and they
right out the gate and we'd go run
through town so they're not just doing
like outers around the academy and stuff
and you would see just the commitment
that those kids had that are trying to
compete for those billets to include the
EOD billets as well that are coming out
as a you know as a naval officer to get
those billets are very hard to get uh
and for us to like miss out on some of
those guys and gals that okay that's
great that they put Navy SEAL or
whatever for the first choice they want
Marines second choice
like they're gonna be good like you know
what I mean like that and they let me
set in on one of these selection boards
which was very I'd never been on an
officer so like CEO selection board no
no no words oh okay and everybody's got
like these little hidden buttons you
know what I mean of whether or not like
you want to vote like yes or no which I
kind of thought was that we're
kind of hiding the button like dude you
can put my button right out in front of
everybody you know what I mean like nope
don't like that one everybody can see
you know what I mean oh JD doesn't like
him oh don't like him uh and you know we
had this uh this this one kid and he's a
nice he's he was a nice kid
um but there's a lot of nice kids that
shouldn't be a marine officer uh and
this this this guy like we're in there
and Colonel Inman was the senior Marine
uh on the yard at the time he uh and and
colonelin gray guy went to the
University of Oklahoma uh just a
phenomenal guy and he's the one that had
me in there he's like yeah hey JD would
like your input you know a lot of these
kids you know what I mean I was like
okay yeah cool I I've never been in here
before uh so I'm sitting there looking
and they got to show a picture and
somebody's going to brief their package
kind of thing and and then you do the
little hidden vote and then you know
they see on the board okay yeah this guy
got enough votes he's going to go in the
go pile so he's just gonna go into go
pile they got this one kid that that uh
that they put up on there and I'm like
oh this guy nice kid seabag with lips
man like TBS is gonna crush him uh you
know what I mean like he's the the
hearts there is just you know he's just
he's not gonna work out as a marine
officer yeah you know what I mean he
doesn't put he doesn't have the
self-discipline
so of course I hit the no and he goes to
the go pile
so I'm a little shocked
so I was like excuse me sir like could
who who voted for that guy like does
anybody here like know him like no
like you know the guy like I've seen him
out there on the remedial physical
fitness field you know what I mean
trying to pass a 10 30. like I looked at
it as if if we're gonna stamp a kid with
the little n star from the Naval Academy
we're going to send him down to TBS then
all of my peers that know that I'm at
the Naval Academy are like oh this is
JD's guys
yeah you know what I mean I don't want
JD's name on this guy because he's not
gonna fare well when they do the
physical fitness aspects and he's like
well I mean it's a it's a yeah we don't
disclose who's voting I was just like I
mean I'm being serious like does anybody
know this kid like I know this kid like
he's we're setting him up for failure
and basically Colonel lemon says well JD
he's he's Legacy
and I'm like okay well that's a new one
what's what's Legacy was dab as a marine
officer
so then I was like okay so we're getting
flounder
remember an animal house when you know
they they took flounder because he was
Legacy I was like so we're gonna get
flounder in the Marine Corps because of
Legacy I thought that was kind of I mean
my dad scouted Major League Baseball do
I get in just because of the Legacy you
know what I mean like that shouldn't so
that was a that was a little bit
disappointing to see that I mean I
should not play a role it should play a
role if anything they should be harder
on him you would think uh yeah so but
other than that uh you know I got the
coolest coolest thing happened to me
when I was there I was coming out uh
football practice it was a class of 2000
a year of 2005. uh and a couple of the
football players were like hey they were
like gunny hey man you're going to
graduate with us
like physical fitness you know what I
mean like they're giving me a PE award
and stuff he's like nope we voted you to
be our honorary graduate and graduate
with the class 2005. and it's it's voted
by the midshipman
uh which was
like that's that was the coolest that's
the coolest thing I've ever what kind of
people do they normally vote for that
not Gunnies uh you know what I mean like
I I did a little bit like it's normally
like some Professor or some other
officer or you know what I mean kind of
of a thing you know it's a mid class of
2005.05. global yeah uh I just went to a
Marine Corps ball with uh Lieutenant
Colonel Adam Horn uh he's got a 53
Squadron down at uh Cherry Point and
when he became the Squadron CEO he he
called me and he's like hey you know hey
JD I want you to be the the guest
speaker at our ball I'm like you know I
mean he goes I'm finally in charge and I
get to pick the guy coming and I was
like dude I was never like in the airway
don't give two shits you're coming
because because you know and when I was
down there with him I mean it came for
he's like I joined the Marines because
of this guy
yeah and it was great for one for the
enlisted marines that were in his
Squadron to see an enlisted Marine
having a relationship with their Co that
like that we could be friends man like
we're on the same team like you know
it's it's a it's a a great organization
and and great to be a part of and uh
then after that I got accepted into the
alumni uh with the Naval Academy they
allowed me in the alumni so I'm an
alumnus uh with the Quantico chapter uh
yeah which is it was like a ring knocker
did you get a ring uh no I didn't well I
got three of them I got three bow rings
uh with the football team uh yeah I did
that I'm really not a a ring guy I had
thought about it uh you know some of the
folks at the Academy were like yeah man
we got to get gunny a ring uh you know
what I mean and and uh but I tell you
what uh that experience at the Naval
Academy I mean uh was was phenomenal uh
I I can't say enough I mean every every
organization has has problems but you
know for what those midshipmen do and
for for what they give you know they're
getting a four-year education and the
service that they give back uh and what
the some of the they got to put up
with up there they make them pay for
that yeah
they're paying for it but they're like I
mean they are quality Americans uh
they're and that's all the the uh
service Academy I would say I mean
they're just a a great group of
individuals and I I mean I had a
complete ball at the Academy yeah no
it's it I've I've gone to West Point
talked to them I've gone to Air Force
Academy and talked to them it's just
yeah very cool very cool uh thing to
look at what happened with the special
Mission Unit you were going to select
for uh well uh that in 2003
um so they have what they call uh it's a
leatherneck program where they take the
midshipmen that want to select Marine
Corps uh their junior year and they take
them to Quantico because give them a
little taste yeah because they're the
only like the Naval Academy doesn't have
to go to OCS
which call it what you see but that is a
little bit of contention I mean you know
uh OCS uh yeah I think they you know
they say oh well we went to bleep summer
well guess what bleep summer is not
Marine Corps officer candidate School uh
you know as you know it's not even naval
officer candidates I don't know I mean I
don't know yeah I don't know you said I
know I don't know I know that Marine
Corps OCS or sorry Navy OCS was was cool
and uh good indoctrination for me I
don't know how it compares to pleep
summer or whatever I don't know but yeah
I'll take your word for it if you say
it's not quite the same thing yeah it's
uh I can tell you I'd rather go through
OCS than four years in the Naval Academy
as far as it was like grind yeah any day
of the week uh you know so like the the
Marine OCS so you know it's just like
with anything else they're going to show
up at TBS and you know oh I had to go
through OCS and you guys didn't have to
go through OCS there was a lot of
midshipmen that wanted to go through OCS
because they had heard you know what I
mean and I was just like look guys you
know what I mean so you don't go through
OCS whoop the yeah you know what I
mean you've had four years at the
Academy some of the folks that do go to
OCS they went to a regular College they
didn't have to put up with a lot of the
crap that you guys are having to put up
with uh while you're here you know you
had to do summer cruises you're
competing for the ability to be a marine
officer which is pretty cool so we take
them down to TBS and they call it
leatherneck we call it purging the squid
uh just because you know I mean the
Naval Academy is set up as a surface
Warfare Officer school I mean that's
that's what it is you're making surface
Warfare officers and there's no Marines
in the brochure so we take them down
there and we you know put them through a
little bit of you know the Land
Navigation a little bit of the field
skills stuff a little bit of the fire
team and Squad patrolling kind of thing
and then they've got uh you know Marine
officers and they've got second
lieutenants that just graduated TBS that
work with the midshipmen and they do
evaluations on some of these kids see
how well they play with others you know
I mean how serious they are how long is
leatherneck program leatherneck is man
that's a good question it might be like
four to six weeks it's really not that
long but neither is neither is OCS
um
so they come down and they run through
the leatherneck program and I got sent
down uh to Quantico
um to one uh at first there was a lot of
contents because people were like oh you
got to do bleep summer everybody comes
here you got to do bleep summer and I
was like well General Allen said I
didn't have to do bleep summer and I'm
going down right just go watch plebe
summer basically or monitor it yeah like
monitor it work it as a senior enlisted
you know what I mean it's kind of like
you know indoctrination of being a
senior enlisted uh you know there was a
there was some cool guys that were up
there at the Academy but I really wasn't
into the whole Chiefs mess kind of thing
like I didn't want to go downtown
Annapolis and do a pub crawl and you
know that kind of stuff uh
so I didn't mix well uh with some of the
other I got along with a lot of the
folks fine I just I didn't mix as well
uh with a lot of the others some of them
had that US versus them mentality us
like us the the staff versus the midship
let's sit around and see how much we can
like make it's miserable like dude these
kids got it miserable enough man and
they're here and just because they're
coming to the academy and yeah it's a
good gig I mean they get a lot of cool
stuff at the Academy you know they got
like a silver spoon coming out of every
orifice of their body I mean you know
who else gets to go on like summer
camping trips and you get to go with
like an air Wing unit you get to fly
over I mean they do some cool stuff at
the Academy and I think it's just
jealousy you know there's a lot of
chiefs Gunnies or you know uh that
didn't get that opportunity and they
just want to stick it to the midship and
as much as they can and you know and
like like what they call like fry in
them like basically like njp but not njp
they call it a fry well all that's going
to do to that kid I mean so the kid did
something stupid I mean they're kids
that's going to hurt their order of
Merit you know what I mean like unless
they're doing something like Grievous
you know what I mean like like come on
man like you know the kid was you know
he's a kid a lot of times I think some
of the folks forget that that you know
they didn't want to see JD when he was
18 and 19. uh
and uh so you know those kind of
those US versus them mentality uh of of
with the midshipman and I tell you what
the the midshipmen they made my
experience at the Academy enjoyable if
it wasn't for them
uh it wouldn't have been as fun like I
had a ball so I ended up down at
leatherneck for the summer and they were
going out to do simunitions and you know
CQB stopped you know coming in doing Mal
uh at the mount facility there and you
know a couple of the guys uh uh the XO
that was in charge the major uh that was
down there uh it's called sign was Pedro
he was a pilot great guy uh Major Brown
uh and he's like hey why don't you come
out man and play some Munitions with the
midshipman while they're kind of taking
them through the mouth so I was like
yeah I'm there like I love doing
simunitions in mouth I mean it's fun you
know what I mean yeah and uh so we're up
there and and I ended up getting up in
the third story uh and one of the
rafters uh in one of the buildings and
I'm making my way through uh the rafters
having a ball shooting midshipmen and
sniper yeah I mean just and I'm slick so
I got no helmet on yeah I got nothing
I'm just I'm having a ball it's a great
day
um and then beams break and I came out
of the out of the third story fell three
stories and uh just hit like uh
break of the rafters that you're in yeah
you know how like the Raptors are yeah
when you when you go back and look at
the rap they were you know it's
government they were just put in with
like long Staples so the rafters weren't
but necessarily like
uh for me to get they were kind of like
how did it even get in the rafters
because like when you went to the third
story there was just like a a cut out
like you know you got like a fake
ceiling like a fake ceiling with a
little cut out like you have in some
people's garages you know what I mean
and you can push up and put a ladder in
and put storage so I just ran and hit
the wall jumped up grabbed pulled myself
up and got up into the rafters you know
what I mean so yeah I got up there uh
and then once I was up in there I was
coming out and turkey peeking trying to
figure out where the midshipmen were
moving around in the town and I put my
hand down boom gone Raptors came out and
I came down three stories uh how come
you went down three stories and not just
falling from because you know how like
the mount has like a building that looks
like it's blown off yeah yeah so there
was nothing there oh okay so I
I'm out
and uh yeah hit went down the the hit
with the left shoulder and then just
down the left side of the body uh so
just and the bad thing was I didn't
knock myself out
so I mean you know like when you go see
the doc and they're like so on a pain
scale of one to ten like right I was
like dude yeah this is a 10. like
because it it hurt
uh and they they uh Medevac me out uh
and took me in and yeah I shattered my
left shoulder uh broke a couple of ribs
on the left side uh broke my pelvis in
three spots and the left ankle
um and uh yeah it was going from 100
mile an hour to zero
and in an instant uh and it I ended up
in a wheelchair uh which was that
that put a lot of stuff like I I didn't
like being in a wheelchair like man that
that was terrible uh I mean I was I was
coming unglued
um
yeah it was just it was a bad a bad time
you know I didn't want to hear the whole
oh everything happens for a reason kind
of thing like that wasn't flying with me
at the time
um
just because I I thought that you know
something that I was
hoping to do that fall was now gone
um and then you know the Navy docks that
are taking care of me you know they were
they were kind of great guys but
um
one of the Navy doctors uh Commander you
know he was like I don't I don't know if
you'll you know you're running and that
kind of thing
if that's going to be happening
and uh well I I didn't like that of
telling me that that's not going to
happen so I went in and uh at Walter
Reed they redid my uh shoulder the first
time and I had to get like a bone graph
and stuff put in and and some screws
uh so I get that done at Walter Reed
which that was back then when it was
like a dungeon you know when before it
hit the news of how Stuff went down uh I
I come out of there
and this happened in the summer of 2003
in January of 2004. I signed up and went
with the Navy Team to run the Disney
Marathon
uh because I was like
yeah I'm running I had already been
running uh being at the Naval Academy
with their athletic department and the
trainers and stuff that they had man
they had me like Aqua jogging and
resistance stuff you know what I mean
and the elliptical and and there was
some you know some of the guys would
come in because like Aqua jogging is
boring as you know what I mean like
it's boring but I'd have guys come in
and get in the pool with me because I'm
just trying to get back I'm still
focused like hey I still got a shot you
know what I mean I can get better
um
so you know that happened in June the
summer and January I went down and I ran
a uh 319. Disney not my best time but I
was I was pretty stoked uh with a 319
and I came back with that big stupid
Disney medal that they give you and I
threw it on the Commander's desk and I
was like there's your PhD don't
tell me I can't run and of course
that's going against Doctors Orders kind
of a thing they got me a new Doc uh the
new Doc that I got he was great uh he
was like yeah push your body you know
the human body is an amazing machine uh
you can you know get yourself back and
get yourself fit uh so I started next
back in the pool swimming I was over
there you know the men's swim team was
phenomenal uh Navy they got a really
good swim program there and the coach
was great so I used to like to go in and
swim with the team
um and I was in there swimming I got out
of the shower one day and and I was as I
was like showering on my shoulder like
something was coming out the back of my
shoulder well so I go over to the
football locker they put the X-ray on I
got screws coming out back to the
hospital you know I mean my body was
refusing some of the screws coming in
I went through rehab uh with that uh for
the second uh shoulder operation and uh
General Allen uh he was kind of my
sponsor he had been moved on he was up
at the Pentagon he's a one star uh
depending on and finally uh you know
John Allen called me up to the Pentagon
and he's like because they put me up on
a Navy Board Med and uh and I I went up
and you know John was like
where where do you want to go
because you're not you're done
like you're not they were not going to
pass you on any kind of jump physical
nothing you know mcmap uh you know even
the shoulder had gotten bad enough to
where they were like dude you keep
monkeying around like you're gonna lose
Mobility
um so that that uh kind of got the
realism uh in there and you know with
him I was hanging out at the Academy and
and uh and then next thing you know uh I
got a call from uh the monitor uh Medi
Knox called me and I was actually at a
bowl game in San Diego out here with the
Navy football and he called me and he's
like hey JD we'd like you to come back
down to Quantico and and you know
oversee the schools uh because they had
a sniper School hrp high-res Personnel
it's basically uh pistol shooting uh
and Savannah Tire uh Small Arms weapon
instructor course at breacher school so
asked me if I'd you know come back down
and I was literally sitting right
downtown San Diego and I'm like dude I'm
in a bowl game with Navy football right
now and you want me to come back like I
don't want to come back so I was like
hey I'll call you when I get done uh out
here I came back and Betty Knox uh gave
me my sergeant uh promoted me gave me a
pin up and pinned me on February 1st and
I went back down to Quantico and gave
them a couple more years back down at
the schoolhouse
uh as a mass art and then left it at 21.
uh and I think it was uh
it was good for me to be down there uh
the colonel that I was working for is uh
Mike Mulligan's great guy and uh Mike
you know trying to get me ready for for
transition like I didn't know this was
not the plan
yeah I wanted to stay at Camp as long as
possible until I get like 30 years and
you know then retire or you know make
all the way to E9 because that was an E8
and uh and yeah it wasn't a it wasn't a
plan so I really I didn't know like what
what I was gonna do
um
and probably the uh the biggest uh
aspect of his you know my wife uh Tracy
uh you know Tom she's like you can
you can do stuff I mean it's one thing
she'll get me she's like you'll work you
know you're gonna show up you're gonna
work uh and you know one of the guys
that taught me back in the day to cast
my net widely Eric Carlson uh he called
me and was like hey man you want to do
some contract work uh with temperature
weapons uh you know special weapons
sniper rifles stuff like that you know
working for L3 Communications so he
called me and I was like yeah do I have
to like you know what do I have to do
because well you know we gotta have like
a panel interview kind of thing and so I
go out to see Eric and everybody that's
on the panel I served with all of them
in the Marine Corps it was like a going
home kind of thing it was like all these
dudes are there and it's just like this
is preliminary uh and so Eric uh you
know brought me in uh and and I mean he
took care of me uh gave me a job
uh because again I I didn't I didn't
really know what I was going to do so
how long did you do that Contracting job
for a couple years and then what how did
you end up uh forming omna which is your
omna International which is your
leadership company is that the right
thing to call it
yeah uh yeah well it's uh experiential
right spiritual learning
um and so it was it was at L3
um and uh you know in the Marine Corps
you know I had the opportunity because
of some of the officers that I served
with that let me tag along and go on
some staff rides uh historically which
was like super I mean you know going to
over and study in Okinawa the battle uh
over there and seeing the reverse slope
defense of the Japanese like what we
kind of went through the Philippines you
know the Korea uh you know what I mean
so just reading and then getting to go
to these places and actually stand on
the exact spot where uh where folks have
been and like I said I'd I had read
quite a bit uh you know I remember
reading you know hackworth back in the
day you know those kind of guys were
just very influential uh on me uh in
leadership and it was just a you know it
was kind of like a uh an experience to
where
you know it's not in a classroom it's
not you're actually on the field it's
very uh it's very Hands-On kind of of
learning and learning how to lead and uh
so
I started with with Amna of
it started to realize that
we could do staff rides
um outside of
the Marine Corps like there's a there's
there's other organizations that are out
there uh you know like at the Naval
Academy we used to take the kids to
Antietam you know I mean they could do
it as a weekend trip we could take an
Antietam you know John Allen he was a
big history guy marine officer of course
love staff rides uh you know Gettysburg
is another big one Corporal Shameless
Garrity used to live up in Gettysburg up
there we called it Marine Barracks
Gettysburg uh you know what I mean so
there was you know going to Gettysburg
the experiential stuff of overseas you
know the Marine Corps was always big on
this uh
um with doing staff rides
and they were a lot of fun
um so again this same guy Eric Carlson
had been dealing with
um the Wildland firefighters uh the guys
Hot Shots smoke jumpers engine crew kind
of guys and I guess they had had a
couple of fatality fires so they did a
tri data study and they earmarked and
went around and looked at different
organizations of how they teach
leadership and they ended up at Marine
Corps University and Eric Carlson was
the operations officer and Eric and they
called over and uh Craig Huddleston
who's with Amna as well Craig's another
one of my great mentors
um Craig was over at uh command and
staff and they were like hey do you mind
if some firefighter guys come tag along
go to Gettysburg sure bring them along
so they went up to Gettysburg and when
they saw how the Marine Corps just took
a pile of dirt what we call a Terrain
model they were like wow this is pretty
cheap we've got a lot of dirt and and
there were so many similarities between
Wildland firefighting and the Marine
Corps uh you know a hot shot is an empty
F Troop platoon you know an engine is
like artillery they've got Aviation
they've got Logistics they've got you
know incident commanders and they were
putting people In Harm's Way they're
making plans they're using terrain
models and they're sending folks out
just like on a military operation so
they really bought into this
staff ride
concept as well as the uh the Naval
Academy
yeah so the Naval Academy
uh with uh Joe Thomas who's still up
there uh with the leadership and ethics
great guy retired Marine lieutenant
colonel Pennsylvania guy Joe and them I
mean we've taken the Naval Academy uh up
to Gettysburg because the team captains
uh with the football and all the sports
that were up there were like hey we got
a guy that can take the team captains
and take them to Gettysburg so you know
through NAA I took the team captains up
there because you know I knew a lot of
the coaches because obviously I spent a
lot of time at their facilities uh you
know what I mean kind of playing around
and I just started like at first it was
kind of a uh
um
kind of something fun to do but I I
didn't know how to run a business so I
basically went online because you can
find everything online and like how do
you start a business.com
and then you know okay well you gotta
you gotta pick a name you got to get a
Don's number you got to get a 10. you
got to get you know so there was a lot
of reading involved
because I had no clue like how do you
get a business license I mean it's just
amazing like
I I became
so more educated you know what I mean of
just starting a business and and getting
QuickBooks like how do you do taxes how
do you run payroll like how do you you
know what I mean yeah you want to learn
a lot of stuff start some businesses
start out business start with just one
you're gonna learn a lot yeah I've I've
just got one yeah I know yeah yeah I
mean but even like I I think the well I
know the first business that I started
was this gym that we're in today and
just the amount of learning that you do
and then you know your next business you
already have some of those Lessons
Learned you can apply them and then the
next business after that when you can
apply some more and yeah but if you're a
young person or or you just got out of
you know the service
start a business I don't care if you do
you know you sell uh you know clothes
pins or something painted clothespins if
you start a business to sell painted
clothespins you're going to learn a ton
you're going to learn a ton and you
might make some money along the way you
might lose some money but you're going
to learn a lot that's for sure uh and
this is how you and I eventually linked
up because at Echelon front we wanted to
do
what we call EF Battlefield and we
wanted to have you know an expert that
has more knowledge about the battles
than we do and that's how that's how we
Linked UP for the first time which was
awesome yeah uh you know we uh so we
started out so I've had the company
since 2010. uh and omna stands for
one-man National Asset
uh and I learned from from Al Gray
that before you decide what you're going
to do
decide who you're doing it with
and you know uh Eric Carlson the same
guy I mean he uh of course I'm going to
do everything with Eric Carr I live
three quarters of a mile from Eric house
and still to this day I run past his
house in the morning I mean he is a huge
impact and and uh another Craig
Huddleston uh Craig Huddleston is the
most interesting man in the world uh he
went from E1
to E7 to 01 to 06. uh a little over 33
it was a drill instructor uh I mean he's
just like he's like one of those guys
that just did everything you know what I
mean he did a tour with the British
royal Commandos over in Europe I mean
he's just the most interesting man in
the world uh and you know he's uh it's
still a downhill ski instructor at Angel
Fire New Mexico he's in his 70s I mean
you wouldn't know it uh the guy is just
he doesn't stop uh huge impact on me uh
in in my life and then all the other
guys uh that uh that that work uh with
Omni you know of course you know we
start out with with Marines
um and then we we started expanding to
where like in Wildland fire they were
like can we develop staff rides for
Wildland fire so you got like South
Canyon fatality fires uh the uh the dude
fire down in in Arizona you've got uh
what the movie came out with only the
brave uh was about the Yarnell Hill fire
we developed that staff ride that's
where I was just at last week uh doing
those because like I said I mean it's
it's experiential leadership uh and it's
not necessarily it's it's armchair
quarterbacking the events but you're not
there to refight the fire or refight the
battle you're there to to take a step
back and look at the leadership
decisions that were made
um and and how could how could we learn
from that how can we move forward uh and
then like teaming up with with you guys
you know what I mean like I can remember
when I when I first like Steve and Jason
uh who I love uh because they are just
Class Act characters
um like when we got done with the first
staff ride uh you know a few years back
and we're we're sitting in the in the
room and and they're like dude this was
so much fun like the inner interaction
with the participants that are there the
people that you get to meet I mean you
remember I mean some of the folks I mean
they even came back and did a little
Bighorn yes uh you know and and just the
experience on the leadership aspect of
experiencing it that they're to me you
just you can't get it from a classroom
you can't get it from a book uh you know
when you're standing you know in the
peach orchard at Gettysburg uh and you
in the discussions that you're having I
mean everybody has a dance sickles in
their organization uh everybody it's
just for ten thousand years we've been
trying to figure out how to deal with
people
and and delivering of a staff ride it's
so memorable
like of being there and you know it's
just so
we basically developed a business around
experiential staff rides uh and you know
and we do it for you know fish and
wildlife U.S forest Service FDNY yeah
San Diego lifeguards I took the San
Diego lifeguards to Gettysburg which was
like super cool like those are a great
bunch of guys and I learned more from
them than they probably did for me like
I didn't know they were sworn officers
and could write tickets but they don't
get a gun talk about the ability to to
use your you know your communication
skills you better be pretty good uh you
know what I mean and you know bringing
them to Gettysburg is like you know in
Gettysburg of like who are these it's
like they're lifeguards like from San
Diego like I mean the whole Baywatch I
mean the guys are just phenomenal people
uh and then we do a lot Orange County
like I know you've done stuff with
Orange County Fire Authority up the road
but then when you meet like the smoke
jumpers and the Hot Shots that's like
kind of like these people like if we
would have had Discovery Channel like
when you and I were kids in the 80s and
I would have seen like wait a minute I
can get paid money to get a chainsaw
which are always fun to operate
and you're going to let me jump out of
an aircraft in the middle of nowhere and
fight fire and I'm gonna get paid like
that's badass and just like with the hot
shots I mean we're gonna put me in a
buggy we're gonna ride around with like
20 to 30 other men and women that just
want to get after it you know I mean
with a Pulaski you know what I mean and
fight Wildland fire uh you know I mean
what I mean they're just great people
they provide a great service to the
country but you know growing up in
Virginia West Virginia we don't have
Wildland fire like here I mean like
everybody out here you all and Cali know
what wildlands West Coast thing yeah uh
but yeah that would be such a cool job
uh and they're just great people yeah
that's a freaking hard job man you know
you and I were talking earlier today and
just when when you've been in the
military and you look at a hill
and you know what it takes to walk up a
hill you appreciate Hills and those
Wildland fire guys man they just
actually I have a guy that guided me a
couple hunts and he's a wild man fire
guy and I mean you want to talk about a
dude that could hoof out some miles bro
I mean this dude was just like okay I
mean with no expression on his face you
know other than like what like where are
we going next no Factor like no Factor
this guy's put some miles in man this is
like mountain goats yeah I mean with
like gas cans and they got like
chainsaws uh and they do a I mean it's a
and they're just a great community of
people uh so I had the experience I do I
do a lot uh with those folks and and
they've expanded to where now with omna
now we've got former I gotta form were
Hot Shots former Wildland firefighters I
got former forest ranger uh you know
what I mean that she works with us I
mean just the the people that I've had
the opportunity to meet over the past
you know 12 years of doing this I mean
it's just it's amazing and of course
like I enjoy the hell out of it which
makes it even better uh you know what I
don't have to go to a cubicle and you
know what I mean we get the and you know
let's make my wife's like what are you
doing over there I'm working
allegedly no you're reading a book
that's my job
I get to read
well uh
you know we were lucky enough to link up
and and and we've you know we bring a
lot of corporate people in we bring
every everyone in a lot of corporate
people a lot of business people in the
go through these staff rides and pass on
these Lessons Learned
um and there's so much to learn from
from these events and the leadership and
the personalities and the people that
undergo them
and
I was talking to you and I always feel
uh kind of selfish because I get to hang
out with you and I was and learn from
these battlefields and from these
battles and I thought to myself hey
maybe we should try and extend this
knowledge to more people so I came up
with the idea of doing a series of
podcasts about the Civil War battles
and
just so everybody knows where that's
what we're doing we're gonna we're gonna
put together a series of podcasts about
the Civil War where it's going to be on
this it's gonna be on this podcast feed
it's going to be Jocko podcast Civil War
Excursion
because it's gonna you know there's some
people that make I don't really feel
like listening to Civil War
and if you don't want to listen to it
that's fine you probably will it's
sitting here talking to you it's
like trying to I can't wait I can't wait
to pull the string on your back where
you just start talking about Civil War
and battles and personalities man it's
awesome and yeah you'll be hearing a
bunch from JD on this feed
um
yeah what do we miss do we miss anything
else
no that's uh that that's uh that's
that's pretty much it uh I I will I
remember when I talked to you like one
of the first times I when your book came
out extreme ownership and of course I'd
read it uh and I had uh some of the
folks that I deal with that that was
like a pre-read uh you know because a
lot of the people that we deal with you
know we we encourage reading lists in
any organization like everybody should
read uh and that was one of the books uh
extreme ownership uh prior to us going
to Little Bighorn so and when you
actually look at it after the fact and
and being with you and all with the guys
with a Echelon front and do it now when
you look at like the battlefield you
could be like well that dude definitely
did not
show any extreme owners oh yeah you know
what I mean it's crazy to go out and you
know I used to tell the platoons when I
was taking a platoon to land Warfare or
or Urban training I'd say look I know
the mistakes you're gonna make I already
know the mistakes you're gonna make
and you're you know you're not going to
cover Move you're going to make things
too complicated you're not you're gonna
have trying to do too many things at
once you're gonna have centralized
command Everything's Gonna Fall Apart
if you follow these Simple Rules you're
gonna do good and it's so crazy to look
back at history and look back at
Gettysburg or Little Bighorn and you can
see oh no covered move right here
everything falls apart oh they too
complicated everything falls apart oh
trying to do too many things at once
everything falls apart oh the
Commander's trying to direct every
single person everything falls apart the
same mistakes get made
in the Civil War in World War II Korea
Vietnam any any War pretty much the same
mistakes get made the same leadership
makes mistakes get made and what's crazy
is they're the same leadership mistakes
that get made in any organization in any
organization it's they don't support
each other they make things too
complicated they don't figure out their
priorities they don't Focus their
efforts and they try and centralize and
control everything and all those things
are bad and when you come out and we
with the next thing we're doing with you
let me look at the dates here it's uh
what do we got
next Battlefield is March 21st through
the 23rd on the hollowed grounds
Gettysburg
you know there is a whole I guess I said
this with Jason you know when Jason was
on there's like a spiritual side to this
there's a leadership side sure would you
go on to that Battlefield and you you
you feel
the sacrifice that was made and it's
very powerful
um both the Gettysburg and Little
Bighorn and I'm sure we're gonna do a
bunch of other battlefields in the
future but if anybody wants to come to
walk the battlefield with us uh
ashlandfront.com check out the next EF
Battlefield it's March 21st through the
23rd
uh
for your company for for omna
it's the omna.com
so you do you do stuff all over the
place you could run a bunch of these
events your people run a bunch of these
events
you're on Instagram Amna underscore
International you're on Facebook omna
International LLC
that's if people want to find you that's
where they can find you
um and that's where they can find some
of the courses that you guys are running
which is awesome
what else Echo you got anything any
questions oh what what year again were
you at Navy
I was at Navy 2003 and left 2006. oh
damn because we'd play them a lot I I
played at Universe Hawaii so that we're
in the um the same conference oh yeah
yeah that's where the head coach at Navy
Ken uh Nehemiah he uh quarterbacked in
Hawaii did you did you play in the Naval
Academy you played against them we I
didn't play the game no but we played
that man the team did but I personally
did not you were on the bench kind of I
was red charity
um but yeah but that was a little bit
before that time though 95 to 98. oh
okay yeah yeah did you get special
treatment at University of Hawaii being
on the football team yes yeah they do
and that may that makes sense too
because a lot of times football brings
in a lot of the money you know so you
know you have that Dynamic for sure yeah
when you know when you look at the at
the football division one compete I can
remember like I had a lot of cool
opportunities like I got to travel with
the team so like we go play Notre Dame I
mean it's big big school that's big
program uh you know I mean and I so I'm
over because I'm a gunny I can just go
wherever I want so I go over to their
locker room
the size of those dudes yeah like
compared to the Naval Academy that
you know I mean they were tree trunks
man these dudes were here I walked back
over one of the quarterbacks at uh Navy
Craig candido I went over to Craig and I
was like dude I'm glad I'm not you today
bro because you're running football JD's
pep talk I'm glad about you
I mean they should set you back to the
back to Annapolis after that
I mean those dudes I mean that's I and
that's where you know when you're
talking about like having these kids
there compete at that level like you at
Hawaii I mean it's a different
that's just a different level of
competition uh playing those those folks
man there's some big and those guys
that's all they do is play football
they're not doing double e and you know
worried about height weight requirements
and service selection they're there to
play football and Go Pro
yeah though that's interesting how you
talk about a guy will be on the o-line
of the d-line then he has to go change
his whole body I was like bruh that's
true you can't be 6'4 290 over 300
pounds and then want to run you know all
these my breaths dude it's not like that
you got to become a different human yeah
you got to become a different human
being like get in and change your DNA is
what it boils down to yeah that's true
even I mean I played a skill position
but even like running three miles you're
talking about eight miles marathons all
that bro I couldn't do that like I could
Sprint pretty fast but man that the long
distance is like a different kind of
running yeah they're they used to do
something called fourth quarters in the
getting ready so it was kind of like
they'd show up in the morning out on the
field and they would have stations like
four corners circuit kind of stuff well
yeah so I I go on of course I've got
cleats I've got everything like I've got
everything the kids have like I love
going to practice you know what I mean
and uh so I'm gonna go to fourth
quarters with the team so first day I go
out and I pick skills players to go with
wrong move
they're these guys they're fast twitch
muscles man they're making me look silly
yeah I mean I think they weigh twice as
much as you oh yeah so the next day I'm
going with the whole line
I I went to one of my seal buddies was
friends with a bunch of San Diego
Chargers and I went to his wedding and
dude these guys are just not they're
like a different species it's like when
you look at a Chihuahua versus like a
Great Dane and you think how do these
the same kind of animal I'm standing
around looking at these dudes going how
are these guys the same kind of animals
me because I don't I don't like this at
all yeah yeah I remember there's like
one of the I think it's one of the
Chargers here training with Sarge and he
was just teaching them some a little bit
of Jiu-Jitsu stuff and I looked at him
he was like I forget it might have been
a fullback or something
and I remember looking after man I
forget I forgot how big football players
are and even thinking back I know the
numbers like I know like my friend Jeff
he was he he actually ended up playing
for the 49ers Jeff ulbrich he was six
one two fifty five and he ran a 4-5. and
I remember at the time I'm thinking like
oh man he's pretty fast for like being a
big you know guy but he's not big
compared to like the t-line or the
o-line or whatever but man me thinking
about that right now bro I'm not used to
that game size anymore usually that's
normal and running on four or five at
255 like when that guy hits you oh yeah
that's that's enough that's not cool bro
you're going down like there's you're
going down you're going down that's just
pure power oh yeah yeah these big Samoan
guys too six five three thirty three
forty and still fast oh yeah yeah these
pulling guards that come there just like
this big mass of a human oh man yes I
forget how big they are yeah
that's why we invented gunpowder oh yeah
awesome uh anything else anything else
JD we're gonna get a big dose of you on
the podcast here
um
anything else from you uh let's talk
about how to support
this podcast
um how to support America right and of
course want to support ourselves
speaking of being jacked yeah
good tool for being jacked creatine yes
we just came out with creatine that's
good how long were you thinking about
doing that
because I remember the idea came up long
time ago yeah yeah just the idea it was
one of those things where we had to be
able to do it at a scale where it made
sense because because we I don't just
want to be like oh we'll just throw our
name in the Hat with everybody else I'm
gonna make it good and all that stuff
but yeah it's been it's been a
it's probably been a few years that we
were had that in the in the queue it
makes sense because it is one of those
supplements that's like reliably good
how can I cross the board you know all
right it's crazy but on that little
video you made when you're like yeah in
the 90s and it's weird that's when I
really heard about it no yeah what's
cool is that that's I I remember when it
came out yeah it came out and I remember
it and everyone's like dude creatine
creatine creatine and I got on Creatine
I was on deployment on the USS Cleveland
the steaming cleave and I brought Cruise
boxes with this protein powder that had
creatine in it and this is the one that
I talk about whether it's vanilla I
don't even like vanilla to this day
because I drank vanilla protein Shanks
for six straight months and I would hold
my nose like it was bad tequila and
she's like oh got it down you don't have
to do that anymore you can get
jonkofuel.com get your creatine get
jacked the other cool thing is they've
done so much search on it now it like
helps it does just doesn't only help you
get stronger helps your athletic
performance helps your helps your
cognitive function like it's it's just
straight good for you
so if you want to get some of that
chocolate fuel.com and that's not to
mention resistance training all the
studies that they have been putting into
that all the benefits of resistance
training so now you got the creatine
supporting the resistance training
supporting all the other functions of
your body yeah resistance training yeah
resisting training no offense JD because
I know you're a runner do you jack steal
at all no it's just uh calisthenics yeah
I do pull-ups I got pull-up bars yeah
pull ups calisthenics right yes that's
just old school Marine Corps no jacking
of Steve
you jacked your shoulder now you're not
Jack and steel
uh what else
discipline go yeah energy drink redefine
healthy all good stuff no bad stuff can
you imagine just having something that's
got no downside how legit is that
that's right that's the legit here no
downside there's no there's no price to
pay no oh well it costs three bucks or
whatever
okay for sure physically yeah
health-wise same thing with a ready to
drink milk did you get a shipment yet
it's gonna be gone there's no way you
can have ready to drink milk in the
house with children I had to make a rule
straight up rule like you're not allowed
to have these kind of they're off limits
yeah oh yeah I open one they drink it
all straight up that's why I made the
rule well we're making as much as we can
we're gonna we we got it on the web
we're so yeah the ready to drink milk
it's freaking awesome it's a game it's
kind of a game changer it is kind of a
game changer you know why I think it's a
game changer because man there's no
reason to eat anything else like you
know maybe you're walking by no but you
know what I'm saying like you're walking
by the fridge and you're like well what
could I have right now and you're kind
of everything's an effort or it's got
downside you know with a Mulk ready to
drink there's no there's zero once again
no downside you don't have to make it
you just put the freaking cap off bro
you're in you're you're correct about
that that's so real get yourself some
ready to drink milk get yourself some
creatine go discipline go
jockoffuel.com at Wawa you're in
Virginia you're going into Wawa yep just
get you cleaning the shelves out yeah
they're cleaned out like all the time
right on yeah we'll send more so if
you're East Coast Wawa you can get stuff
at the Vitamin Shop military
commissaries where work in the exchange
we should be in the exchanges soon
Hannaford's Dash stores wake foreign
ShopRite Circle K HEB Tejas
you know we got you Murphy's down in the
Southeast Meyer in the midwest so go go
get yourself some chocolate fuel get no
downside that's a thing not too many
things in this world not too many things
in this world no downside originusa.com
jeans boots gies
hunt gear rash guards t-shirts beanies I
could how long is this gonna go this
could go a while here's the thing all
made in America right now you know
you're seeing some stuff on the news
right now you're seeing in China there's
a a practical Revolution happening right
now
they're they got workers rebelling slave
labor rebelling it's about time
well that's China that's where your
clothes are getting made if you're not
buying from originusa.com
you're you're
enabling slave labor to happen so don't
do it
get the best quality stuff
get the best quality stuff made in
America
don't support slave labor that's what I
got for you originusa.com it's true also
Jack was a store called Jocko story
I was talking to some Juju who's I
talking to someone was like bruh when
you put a origin Jiu Jitsu on
it's a it's it's totally it's a totally
different different it's a different
thing oh yeah it's like you were it's
like you were driving in a Camry
sure the whole fence against cameras
right apparently yeah but then you got
put into like a Cadillac
you know what I'm saying I know Next
Level it's a different thing it's a
different experience yeah that's a good
hey your brother used to have a Prius
yeah right yeah does he still have it no
see he had that Prius I didn't know what
to think of a Prius right because I've
never been in one sure I got in his
Prius bro that thing was you didn't like
that no that thing was foolish man
I know it gets good mileage and why not
no but I mean it felt it felt like it
felt like economy class yes it was very
economy class I'm sure there's different
levels of interior of Prius I'm sure
that's my assumption I don't know I
don't know how many priests I've ever
been in besides his but
you know I think like you hit the bump
and you feel it oh that whole the whole
deal yeah yeah you're right your economy
yeah that's different so don't do that
man don't get don't get an economy class
ghee no get a first class key yeah yeah
you're gonna feel the difference for
sure especially when you gotta roll
around in that thing too people trying
to choke you with it you will that's
gonna make a difference hey if you
travel first class and then you go back
to economy you hate it yeah it's the
same thing
you're in first class then you go back
into an economy gee you're gonna hate it
it's gonna be pretty much and once again
you're also going to know in your
subconscious mind that like a 14 year
old girl in a slavery position was
forced to make your ghee at gunpoint 14
hours a day but 14 hours a day yeah damn
so just keep that in mind originusa.com
also jungle store if you want to
represent on the past discipline
equals Freedom shirts and hats merch if
you will because this is quality though
it's not like the the cheap free I made
it very wearable we made it very
wearable actually a lot of people say
it's their favorite fitting shirt
Locker
Sherlock is a different thing quality
kind of
custom shirt yeah they are custom but
yeah it's a subscription get a new one
every month cool designs a lot of people
seem to like that one as well so yeah
this is all on jockles there's a couple
common that are I'm pretty I'm pretty on
board with the plan for some of the
t-shirts in the shirt Locker that are
coming out uh subscribe to that
subscribe to the podcast go to Jocko
underground.com look there's stuff going
on with the platforms right now it's
actually crazy to watch
what's going on social media big tech
companies freedom of speech there's all
kinds of Mayhem going on look we gotta
have a contingency plan we meaning you
listening us sitting here contingency
plan
Jocko underground.com if everything
falls apart
we'll be there it's eight dollars and 18
cents a month if you can't afford it
that's okay we got you email assistance
at underground at Jocko underground.com
but listen we don't know what's going to
happen with these platforms
and we can't just look you can't put
your trust
you can't put complete trust into
something you have no control over you
have to control your destiny you have to
take ownership of your future so look if
everything look if we can stay on this
path cool hey we're down yeah it's fine
if they want to let us keep talking and
we'll keep talking we're all good hey we
got no problem with that but I can't
just rely on that we all can't just rely
on the the benevolence
of these people that have no vested
interest in what we're doing in fact
sometimes it could be conceived that
they have a vested interest in not
supporting what we're doing I'm just
saying
that's where we have this dark
underground.com check that out YouTube
subscribe to Jocko podcast subscribe to
originusa psychological warfare
flipsidecanvas.com got a bunch of books
you know what they are
check them out astronaut front if you
want to come to one of these events
with JD and I go to echelonfront.com we
got a leadership consultancy this is one
of the things that we do there is these
Battlefield tours EF Battlefield next
one is March 21st through the 23rd it's
up in Gettysburg
it's it it is going to impact the way
you think and it's going to impact your
understanding of the world
if you come out to that
it impacts me every time
uh so echelonfront.com that's our
leadership consultancy we also have the
Academy online training extreme
ownership.com this is where we teach
these lessons of life
to everyone
through the interwebs which years ago
this wasn't even conceivable thing it
would just seem like oh how can you how
can you learn something over the
internet but Echo Charles how you know
those videos that you make yeah I do
where'd you learn how to do that mostly
the internet mostly
a lot of on the job uh training as well
well you on the field sorry in the field
where'd the knowledge come from they
have the internet see so there you go so
check that out extreme ownership.com if
you want to learn to live your life
better you want to learn to lead
you want to learn to maneuver around the
battlefield of humans which is what
we're all doing go to extreme
ownership.com and if you want to help
service members you want to be active
and retired their families gold star
families
check out Markley's mom mama Lee she's
got a charity organization if you want
to donate you want to get involved
America's Mighty Warriors dot org and
also don't forget about Mike of things
organization Heroes and horses.org
if you want to connect with JD
on the interwebs the omna o m n a v o m
n a.com on Instagram
omna underscore
underscore
International
Facebook omna you just called omna huh
yeah you made it into a word yeah it's
omna one-man National Asset everybody is
a National Asset this starts as like a
tongue-in-cheek thing though right like
hey that guy thinks he's a one-man
National Asset he's the omnist
but then it becomes
on the battlefield in business and life
everyone's job is
critical to A team's success
yeah everybody so there you go uh as far
as Echo and I were also on Twitter
Twitter's hot right now you know that
hey Echo Charles lost all of his Twitter
followers because he got brutal stolen
how did somebody steal that from you did
you did you get fished or something yeah
probably clicked on something it
happened that quick huh yeah well I was
I didn't really go on Twitter that much
so maybe I clicked on one of these lists
you know like 10 things you should avoid
when you go to I don't know Russia or
something okay you know they have those
lists there I always click on them okay
so these are these are click bait you're
on the internet you're surfing the
interweb yeah and then it's like is it
inside of Twitter this is what it'll do
here's a heads up it'll be something
along the lines of this and it's it's
totally my fault where they'll be like
uh oh go back to Twitter
you know like you'll go on the website
it'll be all messy website or whatever
and I'll I'm usually pretty good at
navigating it but then it'll be like oh
navigate back to Twitter so go back wait
you clicked on 10 things to avoid in
Russia yeah and I'll read it it comes up
there's 19 pop-up ads there's a bunch of
weird going on that thing you maybe
even got a little flagged warning that
came up that this is a corruption
probably yeah you just ignored all that
you read the 10 things maybe we should
do a uh an underground podcast about the
10 things to avoid in Russia since we
did get that I don't know yeah there's a
list of some sort so then it says do you
want to return to Twitter navigate back
to Twitter and then you go and then like
if I'm not mistaken it'll say like
oh you're like logged out or something
like that so you log back in
oh bro it was something along those
lines it'll be like confirm or I don't
know something like that bro you yeah
yeah you messed up yeah I walked right
into it um and then my account is just
gone they go in there and they change
your username your password everything
so your email doesn't even show up in
the as the account so I'm like whatever
it's just Twitter
and then like
maybe a week or two later people are
like messaging me like hey someone
hacked your Twitter or something like
you know whatever and then that day with
me and you I went and looked for it it
was just gone everything was gone so I
just signed up under my original name it
was available so what uh how many
followers did you have do you know how
many followers did you have well like I
don't know 70 something thousand seventy
thousand and now how many do you have 70
yeah something like that yeah but you're
bummed out you're sad because the rock
didn't the rock follow you no no Joe
Rogan Joe Rogan forward to your Twitter
and now he's gone yep brutal brutal but
you still follow me now so that's I
think I was gonna I think I might have
been your first oh I was your first
father yeah you were literally
anyways if you want to follow Echo
Charles on the on the Twitter on the
gram on the Facebook I'm on there too at
Echo Charles and at Jocko willink watch
out watch out for the algorithm number
one number two watch out for the hackers
you know that stuff JD anything else no
I'm good right old man well uh thanks
for coming down appreciate it um more
important thanks for your service in the
Marine Corps
teaching Marines how to fight teach them
how to lead it's been an honor working
with you past few years and I look
forward to doing more in the future
thanks to all our military
and tonight especially to our Marines
thank you for holding the line around
the world to protect and preserve our
way of life and the same goes for all
our police and law enforcement
firefighters paramedics EMTs dispatchers
correctional officers border patrol
Secret Service all First Responders
we're only able to live the way we do
because you live your life and sacrifice
the way you do so thank you
and everyone else out there remember
what the Marine Corps says
that while physical health and strength
and well-being is important and it
certainly is
it certainly is
but remember that the principal weapon
is the mind
so read study learn
and of course
keep getting after it and until next
time this is JD and Echo and Jocko out